une production du studio sfr
bienvenue aux sans filtre représenté par
caisse me le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'ont vécu nos invités date site je
peux h 40 avec moi dans une planque on
met extrêmement heureux d'annoncer la
continuité notre partenariat avec ace mi
en fait qu'ils renouvellent leur
partenariat tellement la réponse a été
bonne donc si vous voulez changer votre
caisse de cela à votre caisse
d'ordinateurs vos chargeurs de
cellulaires etc etc on a un code promo
pour vous qu il s f 15 pour 15 % de
rabais sur les produits qu'ils me pia et
reviennent tout juste de lancer leur
nouvelle collection d'automne fait
qu'aller voir les nouveaux design
d'automne j'ai eu un petit smic bic sont
incroyables avec regarder le dos de
votre cellulaire c'est le temps de
changer de caisse a débusqué cette
semaine au podcast on reçoit anthony
bertrand grenier qui est physicien
médical en fait des études de doctorat
en physique donc en sciences d'abord et
maintenant qui complète son doctorat en
philosophie en épistémologie qui peut la
branche de petite fille qui s'intéresse
à comment qu'on acquiert des
connaissances
c'est un espèce de course en 1 2 de
philo en même temps de de science ou la
méthode scientifique sur nous piller sur
les faux arguments sur c'était vraiment
un sport de combat assez d'informations
qui mèneraient à la réflexion puis qui
nous pousse à à douter de
2,2 ce qu'on croit vrai de ce conte de
ce qu'on pense que des commissions sedan
fait on a fait la distinction entre est
une croyance qu est ce qu une
connaissance alors dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui rempli de toutes sortes de
croyances de fausses nouvelles
ça
ça me donne un petit peu plus d'armes
pour affronter ce monde empli de neige
étaient vraiment géant une conversation
fascinante qui comme tu dis remet en
question bien mieux à faire qu'on pense
avoir fait que juste avant de vous
laisser la conversation va les remercier
nos commanditaires bon paquet bonne
écoute le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par nos amis chez pâli cela
vous le savez d'hommes et moi on
approche large de ce qu'on pense avoir
des enfants éventuellement puis c'est la
même chose pour certains auditeurs du
sans-fil même qu'avec ils n'ont des jeux
police lit on un matelas unique pour
votre bébé c'est fait avec des matériaux
biologiques et antimicrobiens donc rien
dans la fabrique qui peut nuire à la
santé de votre enfant les matelots sont
faits en étant régi en fait par des
normes de santé très strictes c'est un
meilleur confort pour votre votre enfant
un meilleur soutien puis merci en fait
pour forcer les meilleurs du sommeil
puis vous allez me remercier car votre
bébé naissant repasser des meilleures
nuits de sommeil par mois + du batteur
la mousse qui utilisait au sein de maple
est une mousse mémoire qui permet un
meilleur alignement du corps de votre
bébé de votre enfant qui fait qu il va
grandir avec une posture de sommeil qui
meilleur donc on voyait propre
possiblement éviter plusieurs problèmes
grâce et la température en plus du mcl
de la mousse est idéal qui permet
vraiment une meilleure régulation sans
doute que s'il fait chaud
luc votre affaire chose va permettre de
garder vos frites s'il fait trop froid
ça va garder au chaud donc meilleur
meilleure moyenne mais à température
optimale la température bissau m si ce
pas important ce qui fait qu'on a un bon
sommeil qui fait trois jours qu'on
trouve chaud on a le sommeil des moins
bonnes qu'il a fait est ce que je me
trompe c'est à des jeux d'épreuves
posture au dos
oui est ce que tu penses que cet aveu un
matelas avec une meilleure mousse
tu avais eu moins de problèmes de boîte
voit en ce moment le cac je vais
à québec christophe les maths le kilo
mais réveille-toi à
mal de dos ne sait pas marcher police
c'est pas mal ficelé on a un code promo
pour vous autres qui le sf 15 pour 15 %
de rabais sur les produits par l'islam
fake ben écoutez bonnut
le podcast est présenté par nos amis
chez même skf qui continue à encourager
le sans-fil podcast parce que vous
continuez à vous acheter des produits
même skate on reçoit beaucoup de
commentaires moi chaque fois que je
parle à quelqu'un dans rhume me parle
pratiquement domaine skate parce que
parce que les gens l'achètent puis
adorent leur expérience le lendemain 4.0
le on en parle sans arrêt mais c'est
parce que c'est la meilleure technologie
de clipper sur le marché il ya une skin
save technologie qui vous empêche de
vous [ __ ] soit les couilles si vous
vous rasez les couilles ou ou boyle à la
barbe la moustache comme toute passion
romantique et penser la reine mais
j'étais assez le moussa sy siffredi
leurs photos même script si donc
imaginer de quoi ni couillon la houle
est parfaite package
au 4.10 il ya tout ce que vous avez
besoin la dengue au lendemain mais aussi
les petits produits désodorisants pour
base et compagnie pepsi est on il ya
aussi les boxeurs m'indiquer moult les
adore ces gens me bats à préférer les
portes même en ce moment même chance
vous les montrer mais je devrais peuvent
convertir il ya utile chouette lazio le
parfum que ph porte ouais moi ça c'est
mon parfum je l'adopté je pensais pas
que j'arrête un gars qui allait avoir un
parfum mais chaque fois que je chante en
mettant dans une situation un peu plus
huppé je me parfume un peu avec le même
ticket pis honnêtement je pense pas que
ça va faire ça mais ça me donne un point
des blues de confiance on a un code
promo pour vous autres qui le sans
filtre 20 pour 20% de rabais et le
shipping gratuit c'est pas un petit
rabais c'est énorme enfants 20% de
rabais que ce n'est pas gratuit fait
procurez-vous s'appuie sur le savoir
deux comparses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anthony merci d'être là merci à vous
merci à vue c'était super quelques
heures sur soi quelque quelques
courriels des fois de gens qui disaient
peut-être que ça serait intéressant de
parler de ce puits puis on l'est
évidemment on n'évite pas tout le monde
qui nous écrit seul sauf que sauf que
quelqu'un a vu tories mais on a dit
aussi on s'est parlé on les taille c'est
vraiment intéressant ça parce que
surtout dans le contexte actuel de co
vide tout ce qui est d'aimer les
croyances et science et pseudo-sciences
c'est quelque chose qui est nécessaire
je pense absolument et c'est ben je sais
pas dans quel côté sur console ou de
n'importe pour le pour le moment avancée
c'est quoi une croyance par exemple
allons-y avec ça parce que j'ai comme le
feeling qu'on entend beaucoup de
croyances pikin j'ai entendu sa
conversation avec myriam sur tête à tête
avec le siag the
town et amener un point par rapport aux
croyances que qui me fait réaliser que
beaucoup des choses que je disais était
finalement des croyants ben c'est le cas
pour moi aussi je veux c'est pas
compliqué on a beaucoup plus de croyance
que de connaissances dans notre tête
habituellement on met une croyance c'est
quoi en philosophie une croyance s'étire
c'est très simple c'est tenir une
proposition pour ouvrir ce que ça veut
dire ça ne me touche je dis je crois aux
licornes ça veut dire je considère que
les licornes existe je pense qu'elle est
si je crois que la terre est plate c'est
que je pense que là tu en es vraiment
plate je pense vrai la proposition la
terre est plate donc une croyance très
générale c'est un peu ce par contre moi
ce que je développe un petit peu avec
matin je me rends compte que il ya très
souvent de l'ignorance lorsqu'on affirme
croire en quelque chose que je veux dire
ce que quelqu'un qui croit que la terre
est plate n'a pas les connaissances pour
prouver que la terre est plate et
quelqu'un qui croit pas au réchauffement
climatique ne pas les connaissances pour
prouver que le réchauffement climatique
n'existe pas donc n'ayant pas les
connaissances il suffit à sa croyance
puis c'est un peu saoul dans lequel je
me vois maintenant c'est quoi une
connaissance pour faire la distinction à
philosophie c'est surtout atteindre la
vérité avec une justification ce que je
veux dire c'est que habito je te dis ah
c'est pas parce qu'être à 20 dollars
dans son portefeuille si tu as vraiment
à 20 dollars dans ton portefeuille est
ce qu'on voudrait que j'avais une
connaissance maintenant je tombais
oiseaux dessus donc la justification est
importante parce que si je dis je t'ai
vu m 20 $ dans ton portefeuille ça veut
dire que je sais que toro moins 20
dollars dans ton portefeuille donc on
peut penser qu'une connaissance c'est
toutes les données qu'on acquiert
directement par la pensée donc admettre
vous voyez dans journal de montréal qui
a eu un accident de voiture à montréal
est ce que vous savez est-ce que vous
avez connaissance qui a eu un accident
de voiture à montréal la réponse est non
ce que vous savez c'est que vous avez lu
dans un journal qui a eu un accident de
voiture à montréal dit si vous pensez v
le fait qu un accident de voiture à
montréal c'est une croyance vous croyez
le journal donc si c'est pour ça qu'on
fait la distinction entre croyants ses
connaissances qu'il faut qu'il a donnée
soit free press une connaissance en fait
le c'est encore un débat au niveau
philosophique mais beaucoup disent oui
ça doit être vérifiée mais le en même
temps est ce que la vérité absolue et
excessive avec le est-ce qu'on est dans
matrix une chose on va considérer que on
atteint la vérité mais pour ce qui est
des connaissances mais ce que j'aime
dire c'est que on suit les faits peu
importe le sens des faits parce que
maintenant je reviens sont les deux
exemples qui te citer les plats this
tous les jours ma camaro climatique
souvent ils vont penser plusieurs vont
penser
que le regard du montage est basé sur
des connaissances oui connaissance le
aussi fait leur guillemets sont erronées
exactement c'est plus c'est pourquoi je
la sais pas mais je crois ce c'est jeu
je le sais parce que telle ou telle ou
telle raison voici comment ces raisons
le flamand 50 que ses prédécesseurs
c'est des arguments fallacieux l'ombre
pétards aux années plus tard mais oui
effectivement très souvent on pense à
bord mais on en croit savoir que la
terrible au même qu'à la terre est ronde
avec ses six sites eu des mauvaises
raisons mais que quand même deux raisons
ça veut pas dire avoir raison si ton
chemin pour aller vers la vérité est
inadéquat m bonnes connaissances même si
tata la vérité des morceaux que la
justification est imprescriptible la
terre et rêveront moi personnellement
m'a t'on jamais allé pas les jamais vu
je les reçois jamais vérifié jamais fait
expérience non plus pour vérifier qu'ils
rompent départagea fermeture comme fer
qui est ronde bloqué parce que je fais
confiance au consensus scientifique
c'est ce dont tu crois le consensus il
doit mettre d'autres à 99.9 %
probablement caire parce que ce serait
étrange que 800 à 1000 personnes ce
tronc mais ait fait la connaissance
moment ça ça reste une croyance envers
le processus mais des croyances plus
forte que d'autres si on en croit pas
tout quelque chose ne s'est remis à 100%
ou à 0% dit on peut avoir un curseur de
vraisemblance m comme on appelle fait
qu'il ya des choses que tu veux croire
beaucoup plus que d'autres puis pour ce
qui de la terre on promet que vous y
croyez très très fort mais maintenant on
est ce qu'on est capable de n'avoir
connaissance que la terre est ronde la
réponse est oui on est capable d'avoir
connaissance ce matin est ce que ça veut
dire une façon de faire c'est lorsque
toutes vos connaissances
pointent dans la même direction et qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul choix possible
exemple vous regardez le croissant de
lune
lobbies aller en floride vous voyagerez
des milliers de kilomètres puis vous
remarqué que le croissant de lune il est
pas du même sens c'est étrange jeu
jacquin la connaissance que je vois un
croissant de lune qui est tout le temps
comme ça au québec qui comme sur mettons
à madrid ensuite vous remarqué que le
soleil en été il est plus haut qu'en
hiver il est plus beau hockey c'est une
autre connaissance il vous remarqué sur
au fil des saisons le vous êtes vous
êtes dans le fond vous aquiris et
d'autres connaissances si vous allez
dans l'hémisphère sud vous voyez j'ai
encore plus loin vous rendez compte que
les les étoiles c'est pas les mêmes
étoiles qu'une que dans le fond nous on
voit ici tout seul ces observations
lancer des connaissances faites vous
êtes capable de vous dire c'est quoi la
forme la terre je remarque le soleil et
rompt la lune est ronde les planètes
sont tout ce qui est gros et massez
ferron ça s'explique aussi par la
physique le parce qu à cause de la masse
mais admettons vous avez pas cette
connaissance la sauvegarde ce que ça
fait c'est que vous vous posez la
question c'est quelle est la forme de
latin qui peut prendre en compte toutes
ces connaissances les saisons comment
c'est quoi les saisons qu'on a au québec
s'est voilé saison qui ailleurs pas loin
de l'équateur ou quelque chose comme ça
vous après toutes ces connaissances le
vous êtes capable de vous dire il ya
juste une forme ronde l'attaqué capables
de prendre en compte toutes ces
connaissances là et si jamais il y eu de
nouvelles informations que vous acquérez
c'est qu'ils bousculent votre chien une
vrai que quelqu'un qui connaisse un on
parle souvent des croyants mais pour
beaucoup des connaissances connaissait
suivent les faits les observations des
expériences peu importe le succès des
entrepôts de mettre de côté ses
croyances non pas les rejeter d'avancé
sur exactement
ça c'est ce point précis là est souvent
un point utilisé
par des gens qui croient des déplanchés
des connaissances alternative en disant
oui mais ça peut tout le temps changer
ça va tout le temps chanté mettons le
cola co vide le way de dire que toujours
une nouvelle information qui faisait
changer la décision de la santé publique
c'était une espèce de façon de dire ils
savent ce qu'est ce qu'ils font qui
suivent rien ils vont au filet alors
qu'en vérité c'est le conseil
scientifique change parce que des
nouvelles informations qui rentre dans
la ligne de compte en fait ce qu'on doit
dire là dessus je pense qu'on va
reparler site où l'échelle de preuves
mais c'est il ya une distinction entre
la science et la recherche la recherche
là dans le fond on a comme une pyramide
de preuve qu'on va sûrement parler
lorsqu'on veut pas dépenser critique
mais ce que je dis c'est que plus on n'a
qu'à des données on a on n'acquiert pas
nécessairement la vérité ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça augmente la
probabilité que ce soit vrai mais ça
veut pas dire que c'est totalement vrai
donc ce que ça veut dire admettons une
étude ont fait une étude sur un
médicament sur celui que vous est ce qui
est capable de traiter telle chose là on
fait une étude est pour en double
aveugle seulement on teste des patients
petites douceurs de fonctionner parfait
l'on monte dans l'échelle on fait ça en
double aveugle le double avec ce que ça
veut dire c'est que le patient ne sait
pas s'il reçoit le vrai médicament et le
médecin le chercheur ne sais pas ceci
donne qu est ce qui donne exactement et
l'on se rend compte que ça marche pas
mais l'os ça vienne changer mais c'est
parce que l'échelle de preuves est
différente autrement dit si il ya une
étude avec un rigoriste et quand même
correct mais une étude avec une règle
aussi encore plus forte ah ça vient
remplacer celle là donc les méthodes
sont plus fortes et dans le coeur de la
coved il ya tellement de données qu'il
faut acquérir sans aucun sens et puis
tous les pays où à peu près se sont
concentrés là dessus donc c'est pour ça
que chacun avait ses études ici et là
chacun avait ses médicaments cesser il y
avait des pseudosciences lac d'annecy
mais n'empêche que la recherche à qui on
est rendu là mais on ne peut pas d'un
serment à qui la vérité donc je poursuis
même loge pas expert des vaccins
responsa que même différents types de
vaccins qui peuvent se créer se produire
selon les données qu'on acquiert
substance et ans est en constant en
constante évolution constante et
rangement puis
seuil des 10 il ya des dossiers des
domaines étudiés qui sont beaucoup plus
vieux si l'on parle mais on parlait
justement de la terre qui est plate
quiron est ce qu'ils ont j'imagine qu'il
ya un un billet de proximité pour
pour
légitimiser la connaissance c'est plus
ça fait longtemps que d'étudier plus ça
fait longtemps que la connaissance bouge
plus plus le comme moi
même je vais même aller encore un petit
peu plus loin si ça fait des centaines
d'années qu'on essaie de prouver que ça
marche puis ça peut toujours pas marcher
ben on appelle ça une preuve négative en
ce que ça veut dire c'est que plus on
cherche sans trouver quelque chose plus
la probabilité ça marche est faible
c'est pratique ça marche pas du tout
mais ça veut dire que c'est très faibles
donc à linverse quelque chose qu'on voit
que ça fait long ça fait même très
longtemps qu'on s'éclate a raison de le
dire même aristote il savait puis il y
est a pris part à d'autres
donc on
ses connaissances le sont
rarement remis en cause donc on a on
peut avoir beaucoup de connaissances non
on ne peut pas nécessairement une
connaissance de nos connaissances et a
dit comment qu'on a acquis cette
connaissance heures donc elle et répété
son appel à la tradition dans les écoles
on apprend qu'elle est ronde ok vous
apprenez que les rondes mais vous le
démontrer pour voir donc oui des fois
c'est tellement
on arrête de se poser la question parce
que tu es sinon on ferait plus de
recherche aux frais de la recherche au
juste les anciennes on recommencera
devons commencer tout le temps le fait
qu'il faut avancer donc c'est pour ça
des fois on doit avoir des croyances
mais si jamais on se rend compte que
c'est fou mais ça on n'a pas le droit de
tenir certaines choses comme vrai parce
que ce serait impossible face soi même
la démonstration d'absolument tout le
temps on n'a pas le talent des finances
tout seul c'est un post doctorat dans
tous les deux a
déjà fait 2 2
ce qui est drôle c'est avec l'argument
team et on l'a tard on
sait que souvent cet exemple le mettons
oui mais le premier qui dit que la terre
était ronde puis tout le monde disait
qu'ils étaient fous pinot noir puis
s'était racheté le aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un des fois va réveiller avec une
nouvelle chose mais c'est peut-être le
galilée d'aujourd'hui c'est le sound
hurluberlus compris et
surtout dans le cadre de l'accueil de
moto il y en a qui se sont présentés
comme des sourds où la piste était moins
seror les nouveaux einstein ou les
nouveaux galilée ya pas eu de révolution
en physique depuis plusieurs décennies
le jeudi 6 ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas eu quelque chose puis depuis darwin
avec l'évolution des grosses révolutions
on n'a pas une nouvelle règle croient
plus aux racines pillon tillon qui on
découvre complètement une telle chose
oui je pense pas je 6 shit quoi tu parle
ça arrive des gens qui m'aiment qui se
prennent pau a je suis un incompris ou
quelque chose comme ça mais il faut
quand même qu'il démontre pourquoi ce
qu'ils disent est vrai il faut qu'il
démontre qu'il faut pas que ce soit
irréfutable non plus donc il faut que ce
soit en mesure d'amener des arguments
des observations des expériences pour
démontrer ce qu'ils pensent si il
démonte pas sa main
désolé mais ça marche pas pour
convaincre quelqu'un il faut lui
présente des faits info il faut que tu
sois capable d'expliquer les
observations tu as aimé si si tu fais
juste des
silences des phrases comme ça c'est à
cause de ce qui se passe dans la sphère
peu importe le gouvernement venus
contrôler pour quelque chose ben il faut
que tu amènes des preuves moi j'ai pas
de problème si jamais tu dis sur elle
démonte jamais parfait mais nous ne le
démontre pas ce magma va être mais en
aucun moyen de foot et de prouver le
contraire non plus donc choisi croire ce
que tu veux croire souvent ces six mois
le souviennent de me mettre dans deux
directions
l'appel à l'ignorance le service de la
paix l'ignorance à l'argument fallacieux
ces trois choses 1 je considère ce vrai
parce que ça n'a pas démontré comme faut
2 je considère que c'est faut passer à
côté de montrer comme ray ou 3 il n'y a
pas d'explication
donc mon explication à la bonne mais ça
c'est un argument fallacieux stadistes
n'ont rien démontré en fait de rien
affirmé était rien dit puis l'autre
chose qui te dit c'est pour ce qui est
des croyances les croyances rassure
mais absolument c'est mieux très souvent
ça peut arriver que c'est mieux un
mensonge qui rassure aucune vérité qui
fait mal c'est à tout le monde en parle
il ya eu le faire machine qui était
pourtant au coeur de la corviglia le
bâtiment mais le rassure nous mais la
science épaules pour rassurer et là pour
trouver la vérité factice si t'aime pas
la vérité
je paraphrase etienne klein qui est un
philosophe des sciences en france et
fils y ait des particuliers il n'est pas
sûr qu'on est intéressé par la vérité
lui dit j'ai l'impression qu'on aime
croire vrai des concepts qui nous
plaisent autrement dit on veut que ce
soit vrai donc on y croit à six mois
j'ai jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui
croit qu'il ya une vie après la mort
mais qui veut pas qu'il ya une vie après
la mort nous admettons
l'examen temps où quelqu'un qui n'aime
pas le confinement puis tu préfères le
social le il faut peut-être en biais de
confirmation qu'on appelle ils vont
aller chercher des informations qui
confirment ce qu'ils pensent donc il va
aller voir les personnes qui pensent
comme lui ou elle pire à telle personne
aussi pensent qu'elle confirme ça sert à
rien donc c'est correct que je vois du
monde mais parce qu'à veut cette
personne ne veut que aller voir des gens
elle veut que ce soit vrai mais la
vérité est indépendant de la personne
qui l'a pense tout te prie un exemple
peut-être que je pense trop du coq à
l'âne mais cette autonomie la vie après
la mort 6 ce qui est utile qui souvent
dans de l'ordre des croyances
religieuses mettant le cpie woippy aussi
de chose à laquelle on n'aura
probablement jamais de réponse le ti ou
l'existence de dieu la vie après la mort
du co du moins si scientifiquement ouf
les effik mans c'est dur
philosophiquement on est capable de
faire des arguments certaine façon le
jeu vous propose un cours de philosophie
le même ton le dualisme qu'on appelle ça
dit que lent mais le corps ces deux
entités différentes c'est c'est vraiment
pas à jour depuis descartes le jeu
produit que c'est terminé mais dans le
sens que notre âme et notre cas c'est la
même chose pour des gens qui sont
physiques alice il ya le dualisme il ya
encore des débats la thur je dis pas que
c'est la vérité mais si il semble qu en
comble il se passe plus rien mais ces
arguments en faveur de l'inexistence de
dieu aussi mais ça dépend c'est quoi la
définition du ces se comprend même si ça
me semble pas trop petit pour me
contredire mais quelque chose qu'on peut
prouver mettons hors de tout doute non
non mais il leur a dit qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant
philosophiquement ou scientifiquement
avec ces choses le camp sera jamais
capable de prouver hors de tout doute
que la croyance devient plus
une question de vraiment de choual de
choisir de croître et puis même de des
tiges d'après moi le pas des gens qui
croient en dieu il ya quand même une
part d'eux qu'ils le savent pas mais
décide quand même de croire - on n'a pas
croire que l'on peut s'en aller dans
beaucoup de directions là qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ça ça dépend est ce que
c'est si ça ne nuit pas la personne même
temps la personne qui croit en dieu puis
et qui croient à la vie après la mort
sans ride mais tant mieux si par contre
alain bosa d'autre que toi aussi tu
crois pas tu vas aller en enfer août et
à l'impôt cette doctrine si on me dit
lui ça peut être différent
si on a une façon de je sais pas si tu
voulais qu'on convaincre la personne que
ces arguments ça marche pas le nom mais
c'est plus ce qu'ils émettront
c'est quelque chose qui plie en compte
qui devrait être pris en compte ou kid
mettons dans une société est
il le
même temps
les écoles religieuses qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ce look hockey une école
religieuse moi j'appelle ça un oxymore
pourquoi un oxymore ces deux termes qui
sont contre ces montées en mode et
sandro
pourquoi j'appelle ça un maximum c'est
que la religion lors on va pas parler
les valeurs de la religion parce que les
religions si c'est pas juste des
croyances là on va se focaliser
seulement sur les croyances les écoles
les collèges et les universités à mon
avis c'est un lieu d'enseignement de
connaissances et non de croyants donc
c'est pour ça que
je dis les religions mais n'importe
quelle croyance c'est un pseudo science
c'est bien plus large que seule une
voyance donc n'importe quelle croyance
ci est le poète et démontrer comme vrai
ou du moins qu' on n'est pas capable de
faire confiance et pour reproductive on
doit pas l'enseigné entre paul
enseignants dans les écoles et collèges
et universités
c'est seulement les connaissances qui
doit être enseignée maintenant on peut
s'en aller dans vraiment bonne direction
là qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce nom mais
c'est juste la distinction que je vois
peu pression au contraire notre appel le
faisait dix ans que je vois c'est
mettons sur l'eau science on peut
prouver leur inefficacité mais tentez
web 1 et 6 ok on va on va aller dans
cette direction est ce qu'on est capable
de démontrer que dieu existe pas ok
c'est quoi ta définition dieu ben si ta
définition dieu c'est créateur de
l'univers je suis pas capable de
démontrer qu'ils n'existent pas mais
maintenant si tu me dis que ton du
répond prière bastos à ce test est sale
a été testé chez aziz sow salle a été
testé puis il dit techniquement c'est
testé massivement oui à chaque jour non
mais on a fait il ya vraiment des études
en double aveugle qui on allait faire là
dessus
du moins la méta analyse que moi j'avais
vu il ya même un effet nocebo qu'on a
perdu et l'effet placebo c'est quand
c'est positif sinon c'est beau c'est
quand c'est négatif non c'est beau ce
que c'est que admettons je vous donne
des médicaments je vous dis si le
médicament mais vous savez aussi le vrai
médicament mais ça se peut que vous ayez
vomissements diarrhées à temps admettons
que vous avez vous me demandiez on ne
parle
donc vous avez les conséquences mais
vous avez pas juste les effets sont
donc les mettons la priorité est payée
même un effet nocebo sur les prix y
assure suis pas capable de vous
expliquer pourquoi le mot j'ai pas
compris totalement semaine 76 démontrer
comment ces coûts qui s'y passe obama
qu'il pensait que dieu l'abandonner
parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout me semble
c'était des gens qui étaient mal en pis
que plusieurs centaines de personnes
plus il ya des gens qui ont prié pour
des gens qui étaient mal en pis y en a
qui ont pas prier pour d'autres gens
pleut il comparer les deux
les auteurs les deux personnes les deux
groupes ne savait pas qui
d'autre prier pour eux ou non donc
c'était vraiment en double aveugle
qui s'était pas les personnes mariées
personnes servant aux cabrières c'est
d'autres priaient pour rire dont oui oui
fallait s'assurer que ce soit bien vous
allez me permettront peut-être que si tu
mets tu aimes
ton espoir dans mettons dans les prières
mais cap mais qui ça fait en sorte que
qui était peut-être moins c'est juste et
médicaments parce que le jury comprend
que ça a été fait mais je les polluent
pas donc faudrait faire une petite revue
littérature l'étude mais ce système
avait pas dit que dieu n'existe pas mais
ce que ça veut dire c'est que la prière
ne fonctionne pas donc
ça répond pas pour le moment si jamais
ça on voit que d'autres études plus tard
le ca change d'avis et pas de problème
mais pour le moment ça marche pas donc
si jamais tu dicton dit répond priem
aujourd'hui écoute et des méta analyse
qui pour le moment on dit ça sent pas
fonctionné parfait maintenant quel autre
chose que ton dieu est capable de faire
et capable d'interagir avec le monde il
ya plein de choses qui se teste donc
tout ce qui ce test ben alors on vient
de le dire on est capable de le tester
tous les tests ont été testées et
éprouvées comme pour l'instant non
concluantes c'est la formulation pour
l'instant ben c'est ça c'est que ça fait
très ça fait très méthode scientifique
en fait de dire jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
j'allais juste il fait que peut être
grande révolution méthode scientifique
qui était de payer des gens ne gagne pas
tout le temps mais d'essayer la gravité
a été a été trouvé
est ce que c'est ce que ça c'est la
preuve que habito scientifique qui joue
ce week-end ça prouve qu'ils
fonctionnent bien dans le fond pourquoi
ça fonctionne très bien c'est qu'elle
est fiable stade rennais et
reproductible c'est si on fait une
expérience ici si on fait une même
expérience au japon sans faire la même
chose si ça fait pas la même chose le
stanc c'est très intéressant parce qu'un
recherche on va dire ok le quai ce
qu'est ce qui fonctionne pas ou est ce
que nos méthodes étaient exactement les
mains mais ce qu'on a changé quelque
chose mais si
l'exemple banal en mathématiques de plus
de ça va donner quatre partout sur terre
le soleil von teese il ya des
observations qu'on est capable de faire
et elles sont reproductive donc c'est ce
qui fait que la science est fiable parce
qu'elle et reproductive télé les jeter
les avis on vole la technologie a été
développée en fonction de deux de la
science beaucoup mais c'est ce qui fait
que la science on c'est une méthode
qu'on qu'on peut y faire confiance si
jamais on trouve une autre méthode plus
tard qui va remplacer la science piqué
plus fiables mais alors ça c'est pas
plus compliqué mais je voulais justement
les exactement le dans le fond si on
tombe vraiment le au début c'est quoi la
méthode scientifique ok la méthode
scientifique en une phrase c'est une
méthode pour acquérir des connaissances
et comprendre le monde il ya beaucoup de
choses la méthode scientifique bien vite
demain avez vous vu ou lu le seigneur
des anneaux
oui oui collabore avec ce
[Rires]
bon ben je peux vous dire que gandalf et
scientifique ok parce que sa demie du
mais bon
on peut passer il ya beaucoup de choses
et beaucoup de concepts la science
mangement résumé 4 1 une revue de
littérature il faut voir qu'est ce que
les autres en fait dans le monde ce
sujet si on le fait pas forcément un
grand mais c'est mieux parce que des
fois on retrouve et la réponse
directement des fois on va chercher pour
quelque chose qui a déjà déjà été fait
deuxième la méthodologie quelles sont
les méthodes qu'on va utiliser pour
essayer de démontrer qu est ce qu on
pense notre hypothèse quoi que ce soit
3e les résultats que ça ne donne pas 4e
l'interprétation des résultats
garda qu'est ce qui est fait il ya vu
bilbon avait là n'ont rien fait est ce
que c'est la note seront bons bien la
nature y retourner vers tournai des
bibliothèques des anciens écrits
regarder au seul le feu peut révéler
parfait méthodologie on va le mettre
dans le ferons à ce que ça donne il met
dans le feu claquent résultat il ya des
écrits qui apparaissent conclusion
interprétation la probabilité est assez
énorme que ce soit la nature quand
d'alfie sciatique s'écoule
très fort mais ça image bien le truc en
fait puis
comment met-on si le y retourne à
[Musique]
la cité blanche
non il retourna street puis il voit dans
les écrits amena street pour chercher
puis qui lui savait que dans cette
bibliothèque la salle est pas être la
shit qui allait trouver qui loin c'est
réglé mais qu'est-ce que
caisse comment on peut savoir où
chercher dans le fond c'est moi mettons
je veux dire ok du jeu j'aimerais savoir
l'effet de ce pom a mangé une pomme et
45 minutes avant mon entraînement ok -
où je trouve sur moi pour moi qui pour
un chercheur qui a pas accès
nécessairement à tout les papiers
scientifiques et pas nécessairement le
temps de chercher des médailles
se soucier vraiment intense parce que ta
question est quand même super site et
donc on n'a pas le choix d'y aller avec
ses google cars pas mettre nos d'aidé
dans le fond des jeux des articles des
journaux qui répertorie beaucoup de
journaux scientifiques puis une
différence entre un journal comme le
journal de montréal versus un journal
scientifique parce qu'il ya une revue
par les pairs ce scandale fait pas une
revue par les pairs
on dit qu un demi dieu est vraiment
laid ou qu'on cherche on peut chercher
google scholar ou des choses comme ça
mais déjà juste dans des moteurs de
recherche internet cancon écrits
scientifiques quelque chose il ya des
journaux qu'on est capable de voir
qu'ils sont scientifiques c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont des revues par les pairs mais
par contre pour l'entente ont reparlé de
journaux prédateurs le parce que les
journaux prédateur c'est pas des revues
scientifiques c'est des gens qui ont
appris qu'ils pouvaient faire de
l'argent qu'ils ont inventé leur journal
on va demander aux chercheurs de nous
envoyer sur ils vont me donner les deux
pièces une nouvelle publiée pour voir
même pas les donc sur ses pots
scientifique parce que pas une revue par
les pairs de revue par les pales c'est
maintenant 3 4 personnes qui vont
vérifier que ce que tu as fait la paire
méthodologie été bonne tt résultats
semblent à est adéquat une
interprétation correcte pour était trop
dans le champ donc puis je dirais le
gros problème c'est que la majorité des
articles sont payants s'il faut en
acheter les articles il y en a qui sont
gratuits et l'abstract stasi le résumé
de l'article lui il est toujours gratuit
est toujours gratuit donc au moins tu as
accès à une page qui résume l'article
[ __ ] quand même la conclusion savoir
si tu peux manger une pomme si ça a une
influence texane de pau peut-être
thunder
métier parce que juste ce que tu viens
de dire le ca me parait comme comme un
énorme problème ouest pour le public en
général
moi parce que c'est beyrouth of de
différencier qu'est-ce qui est un
journal je commence quand je l'appelais
un journal scientifique pas mais dans
d'autres non mais j'aurais présentant le
journal prédateurs oui qu'est-ce qui est
un journal qu un journal scientifique
versus qu'est-ce qui est un journal
prédateurs qu'un la seule source que tôt
pour chercher si google liste journal
prédateurs vous allez l'avoir
on met en même temps c'est que le site
ce culte va trouver liste journal
predator sur le site mois-ci que tu
connais pas la légitimité non
effectivement en fait ça vient avec un
petit peu notre curseur de vraisemblance
le savez pas combien de temps vous avez
à faire
sur la recherche moi je vous dirais
qu'elles sont les connaître les
connaissances quelles sont les
conséquences si ce que vous pensez et fo
terme et on se mange une pomme avant ton
d'entraînement je vais pas infini de
temps à mettre à chercher si oui c'est
sur exactement le titre [ __ ] une
certaine très grosse influence sur ta
vie en moins qu'on se rend compte que
les pommes segment notre espérance de
vie par les américains d'autres
laiteries cdc dessus par carte sim et on
m'a recherche c est ce que le vaccin il
peut mourir c'est ça ça c'est vraiment
ça vaut la peine a bola perdre le
chercher pendant quelques heures au
moins je dirais si quelque chose que je
recommanderais ça s'appelle des review
c'est un résumé de beaucoup d'études qui
ont été faites qu'est ce qu'on connaît
sur le sujet donc si vous écrivez review
il ya même des journaux qui sont
spécialisés dans les review il ya
probablement des journaux prédateurs qui
ont publié des reviews aussi c'est
peut-être c'est plus rôle parce que
review il n'y a pas de nouvelles données
vraiment ça fait juste répertoriés
qu'est ce qu'on sait sur le sujet et
puis c'est très vague donc en général
c'est bien vulgarisé mais en même temps
tu sais si on s'en va parler de
molécules de l'acide citrique de chapeau
coin le cse on va avoir de la misère
donc j'avoue que au niveau
vulgarisation l'article scientifique
ccpo super le nom peut-être s'en tenir à
ce qui vulgarise les artic des
vulgarisateurs scientifiques qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent de ce donc je dirais
vraiment c'est quoi les conséquences de
ton de ce que tu penses comme at-on
affaire de la pomme puis des vaccins les
vaccins c'est très important mais la
pomme j'ai l'impression que c'est papa
trois semaines à temps plein la tuque
lui mais les vaccins je te dirai pas ce
repas c'est une journée qu'on empêche et
un autre à fin vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'aller voir les articles scientifiques
vous pouvez vous en tenir aux experts
c'est à dire ouais ouais ça doit porter
un autre problème comment reconnaître un
exploit ce site offre parce que comment
on peut savoir l' expertise d'une
personne si nous mêmes on n'est pas
expert dans le domaine sinon on s'y
connaît même pas dans le domaine puis la
première chose qui revient puis j'ai
moins sûr c'est assez une expérience et
les autres disent que c'est un expert on
c'est un cercle vicieux qui espère que
ses hommes ont donc moi ce que je dirais
c'est d'abord il faut que l'expertisé de
l'expert ne soit pas une pseudo science
on peut reparler comment qu'on distingue
la science la pseudo-science tantôt mais
il faut pas que ce soit ne faut que ce
soit quelque chose de reconnu mère je
reconnus par des experts consultants
sont reconnus comme une certaine
expertise de même pas besoin de
l'astrophysique on sait que tu es
capable de faire certaines recherches
pour observer que l'astrophysique c'est
les observations qu'on est capable
d'aborder donner fière détenir
productive mais trop c'est l'enjeu pour
observation de la lune de mars de ja
vous pour la médecine c'est peut-être
plus difficile mais n'empêche que si
vous avez
si vous faites juste
écrire le concept que vous avez en tête
et vous écrivez en plus plus gros
science si vous avez beaucoup de
résultats que ce soit dans google yahoo
ce que vous voulez que c'est des
pseudosciences
ben alors peut-être que il faudrait
faire un petit frein à ce sujet la
maison l'astrologie tu l'astrologie que
c'est pas de l'astrophysique sepa
l'astrophysique l'astrologie c'est en
fait il ya quelques milliers d'années
c'était une façon d'expliquer le
comportement humain de parler les
positionnements du ciel ou quoi que ce
soit puis ça s'était très facilement
puis c'est démontrer que ça marche pas
mais admettons
le je veux pas perdre le fil parce que
le tu me dis
maintenant quelqu'un qui se présente
comme un astrologue experts espèrent
l'astrologie tous les autres farhat
rajhi disent qu'ils sont experts un
mouton film et l'astrologie n'est pas
une expertise donc là on a un problème
messi mais quelqu'un prêt contre
argumenter oui mais ceux ci qui
nécessite bien les résultats aussi
serrés dépasser les résultats c'est
l'effet vraiment c'est l'effet de la
méthode scientifique et faire la méthode
icp c'est un témoignage d'expert est en
dessous de toutes les études qu'on a sur
le sujet une et dix journées doit toutes
les données qu'on a acquis sur le sujet
sont meilleurs que le témoignage de
l'expert peu importe l'espace maintenant
si mouton dans le cadre de l'accueil
vides il y aura huit experts qui disent
qu'il faut aller dans tel direction puis
en a cent mille qui disent qu'il faut
aller dans tel direction la probabilité
que cent mille personnes ce qui trompe
verts se suivre quand je dis ça emmerde
je dis que c'est 100 mais l'expert aux
600 milles l'expert en virologie
médecins et tous ceux ou même le
réchauffement climatique ceux qui sont
géologue qui s'y connaissent sur le
réchauffement climatique
s'il y en a huit qui disent qu'il faut
aller d'un bord pis il y en a cent mille
qui disent que le réchauffement
climatique existe ben oui vous avez une
croyance veut pas connaissance vous avez
connaissance qui en a eu huit critiques
qui font dans une direction qui en un
sens mais résiste mais bon dans une
autre action mais vous avez une croyance
hockey est ce que le réchauffement
climatique exige nous sommes fiés à la
probabilité qu'ils en hausse en multi la
vérité sur ce suite lorsque la
probabilité plus grande
comment je fais pour savoir qui à 900000
d'abord puis de l'autre parce que j'ai
pris une semaine le temps dans une vie
ou d'écouter 100000 témoigne de sa
classe il ya dans des review dans des
méta-analyses idiot j'avoue qu'il faut
aller voir sur par exemple parce que je
prends capable de dire écoute tu es
capable d'être découvrez patoisant
internet sans information sans livres
mais si tu veux avoir des méta-analyses
même au début au milieu des témoignages
d'experts par exemple ça arrive dans des
conférences internationales que il ya un
an fidèles - dans le cas de la coved
mais mettons un amphithéâtre de 500
personnes plus tu vois que y'en à 497
qui disent oui à telle chose il y en a
trois qui disent non à telle chose bah
tu l'as dans le dans le review pas que
je sûr c'est une information pour toi tu
sais que tu as lu dans un journal qui
est écrit qu'un à 490 bastille mettons
mettant quand
j'écoute le pharmacien puis qui me dit
mettons du consensus scientifique toute
l affaire c ce je le crois oui je crois
quand même une personne oui c'est vrai
que comme ça c'est exactement aux
témoignages tôt un témoignage donc si tu
veux vraiment chercher plus loin il faut
remonter à la première source pascal
mattes aussi lui 10e puis moi je te dis
la même chose c'est que nous deux on se
fie sur exactement le même journal même
artistique ou ce que vous voulez en mai
mais l'analyste donc au final si on
remonte à la première source juste une
source ce que je veux dire c'est
maintenant les médias il ya cinq ans
mais dieu qui disent la même chose ça y
est on a 50 sources mais finalement ils
se sont tous basés sur le même
témoignage bateau juste une source donc
ce
que ça veut dire c'est que si on remonte
à la première source le ça va être la
meilleure connaissance que tu vas
pouvoir obtenir du témoignage
oui tu crois le ferment à chiens mais en
même temps c'est combien de temps tu
veux investir ce sujet donc si tu veux
vraiment investi beaucoup de temps je te
dirai voisine mais si tu veux investir 1
2 minutes le service d'haïti
je te dirais écoute des experts mais
comment tu peux retrouver les experts
rendues minutes leur côté ont dit les
experts d'un autre côté on dit
l'argument d'autorité estime son fils ou
sa fille ses soeurs exempt l'argument
d'autorité c'est surtout un sophiste
lorsque la personne n'est pas expert sur
le sujet tient maintenant un médecin
parle d'astrophysique il peut s'y
connaître en astrophysique gagné
passionnés de soya pas problème sauf que
ça veut pas dire qu'ils s'y connaît donc
c'est mieux de se référer à une brise
béton ou d'autres mais ça veut pas dire
que ce qu'il dit est faux c'est juste
que l'appel à l'autorité et il faut
juste faire attention de dire je me fie
aux experts mais ça veut pas dire que
les experts ont raison mais l'argument
d'autorité surtout envers ceux qui ne
sont pas experts sur le sujet mais des
fois il ya des experts sur le sujet qui
peuvent dire mais c'est même pas une
question mettant le
l'exemple du du médecin qui fait le
médecin de famille à qui donne des
conseils de nutrition mettons que les
construit après ça sont entendus par un
oui nutritionniste qui fait ça aucun
rapport à l'histoire la csn existe un
médecin qui la donne qui lui est un
expert dans quelque chose d'autres
outils dans un domaine de santé qui ont
rien à voir de la nutrition le dégoût
d'eux parce que c'est ton moins sait-on
que ça c'est ton médecin et on peut
toujours aller voir d'autres experts si
jamais vous avez un problème votre
voiture vous allez vous au garage pour
bus c'est le mécanicien ou qu'il faut
faire c'est un bon exemple mais dont le
t3 mais deux piasses ça va coûter 3
milliards bon ok parfait petit 3000
pièces bon est ce que j'y fais confiance
on a envie encore à quelles sont les
conséquences de sûreté le médecin qui
donne des conseils judicieux c'est quoi
les conséquences de tueur on peut y
poser la question on peut aller voir
d'autres pour leur poser la question
c'est quoi les conséquences si je bois
juste du jus de fruits puis
rien d'autre pour rien l'autre donc
bâton en mai cannes et bien vous pouvez
aller voir d'autres garages vous pouvez
aller voir d'autres mécanicien
exactement comme le médecin et vous
pouvez aller voir d'autres médecins
nutritionnistes vous surtout qu'en plus
on a un système public le jeudi vous
pouvez aller dans un autre hôpital
j'ai entendu parler de lui et puis je
suis pour ce qui me disait deuxième avis
deuxième avis c'est un deuxième avis
puis le on parle de différencier des
experts puis ce que tu disais qu'il
fallait remonter
au champ d'expertisé -
comment est-ce qu'on discerne la
pseudo-science maintenant si on se rend
compte que cette personne est d'y être
un expert on remonte au chant expertise
qui au final les pointes mais comment
est ce qu'on fait pour savoir ce qu'est
c'est quoi une solution une pseudo
science en une phrase est un concept
n'est pas passé les tests de la science
autrement dit ça donne des résultats qui
sont pas reproductibles on peut penser à
l'homéopathie l'astrologie de tantôt
donc mettons l'homéopathie
on teste l'homéopathie c'est à dire on
fait on donne des médicaments pour
l'homéopathie mettront sur les jeux pour
leurs hurlements le tight tout ce que
vous voulez nombreux quoi dire là je
prépare une maladie quelconque on donne
un placebo c'est à dire ce qui n'est pas
l'homéopathie puis à d'autres on donne
l'homéopathie pour ouvrir la pilule
d'homéopathie puis est ce que le même
petit capable de battre le placebo la
réponse est non bon ben c'est une pseudo
science parce que c'est ça pas été en
mesure d'aborder les résultats fiables
et reproductive pour ce qui est de
battre le placebo ou encore de la
médecine l'astrologie on voyait avec
l'astrologie comment qu'on fait pour
vous et que l'astrologie n'a pas d'
influence sur le comportement humain ou
quelque chose comme ça mais parfait
c'est quoi que les astrologues 10 sur ce
qu'ils sont on est homo de jambi pince
il ya comme des deux moulins fin janvier
début février que je crois aux matons
sur les verso les verseaux doivent être
tel tel tel tel comportement parfait
on va regarder tout ce qu'ils ont ce
comportement deux et on va regarder s
qui sont verso on va regarder maintenant
sûrs qu'ils sont verso qui ont regardé
espions ce comportement de puis on va
même regarder on va même il ya plein de
façons de faire des tests on va donner
un billet qualif qui s'appelle l'effet
de
barnum qui ont dit ce que tu veux
entendre t as tu es sur une grande
confiance en toi tu après tu est réservé
à l'occasion mais tu peux être
extraverti d'en tirer des choses qui
réunit tout le monde puis on le donne à
tout le monde si la 80 % qui disent que
oui ça l'est représentent bien mais on
leur tour donner la même feuille on se
rend compte que a aidé verso ou ça
change absolument rien donc on est
capable de vraiment bien
je connais
donc on est capable de voir que ce n'est
pas reproductible temps forts que c'est
pas fiable ce qui fait que c'est pas une
expertise
juste une façon de voir que c'est une
pseudo science
maintenant pour ce qui est
dans le fond c'est comment que ça n'a
pas passé les tests de la science et oui
il faut malheureusement allé voir dans
des articles scientifiques si c'est le
cas si vous avez un endroit pour
commencer les méta analyse ce qui
répertorie absolument tout c'est quoi le
consensus ce sujet même certains ainsi
que des fois wikipedia c'est pas de
serment une source mais c'est important
et qui cite des sources donc sur
wikipédia vous êtes quand même capable
d'avoir ils vont citer des méta-analyses
à l'occasion donc ça peut quand même
être quelque chose qui pourrait
correct parce que vous vous êtes capable
de remonter à au première source du mois
certaines première source avec ce
portail sinon pour ce qui est des
pseudosciences on a encore la question
et c'est que les conséquences si c'est
faux ça nous dit pas si c'est vrai ou
faux le mais c'est quoi les conséquences
si c'est foot vous allez chercher
beaucoup plus si salle une grande
influence sur votre vie versus apte et
l'astrologie c'est beaucoup d'influencé
en moins quelqu'un soit vraiment intense
qui disent à telle personne coc
clairement un toro de telles affaires
puis donc ça veut dire qu'il peut pas
être avec un scorpion parce que telle
affaire ça c'est vraiment une grande
influence sur ta vie mais si je suppute
amusé et puis je suis dans le journal de
temps en temps je pense pas qu'il ait
besoin de faire une revue de littérature
complète pour savoir si c'est qu'avec le
sait ok
souvent réponse peut encore ça ouvre la
porte après l'autre a formé bon mettons
qu'on dit
c'est parce que parce que la science la
méthode scientifique c'est surtout dans
l'est dans les milieux universitaires
que c'est fait on des milieux de
recherche universitaire les mieux de
recherche universitaire ça fonctionne ça
prend du financement pour faire des
recherches apprendre ces choses là c'est
un autre aspect qu'on pourrait checker
plus tard mais
il y aussi un enjeu de deux temples de
pertinence métier je vois mal une chaire
de recherche à l'université étudiés
qu'est ce que c'est quoi les effets de
mètres du pissenlit dans ton eau chaude
avant d'aller se coucher mais ton le
style ouais puis fait clottes
difficilement tu peux aller trouver une
étude scientifique qui dit que peut-être
que sa relaxe des fonctions musculaires
et on le sait puis
pilote va avoir une pseudo science qui
va arriver en dix ans et on a fait
tester ça avec 10 personnes différentes
et vraiment pas une grande analyse à
l'aveuglé gros à former comme c'est la
seule information qu'on a c'est eux qui
ont décidé de faire du pissenlit nantes
on ne puis que ça l'air de fonctionner
ok on va y aller là on va y aller avec
l'échelle de preuve c'est quoi l'échelle
de preuves une très bonne phase on
distingue la science de la pseudo
science et la pseudo science c'est quoi
le meilleur argument qui peut vous
donner si vous précis la personne devant
vous vous présente des témoignages c'est
vraiment pas bon c'est ça a marché pour
moi un témoignage c'est pas c'est pas
une preuve malheureuse mais pas pour
quelque chose comme ceux ci est aussi on
essaie de faire passer le concept par la
politique par exemple par un ordre
professionnel par des lois c'est encore
moins bon c'est parce que si la science
pour démontrer que ça marche ben là si
tu essaies de faire passer sa part la
politique et à une amende de 100 corps
pays bas il y en a qui ont des hommes
ayant nos professionnels d'homéopathie
en ontario le yoyo des ordres
professionnels lors professionnelle en
passant c'est là pour protéger le public
c'est pas là pour dire que ça marche
c'est vrai c'est le pôle délimiter les
fonctions de ce que la personne dit
qu'elle est capable de faire ça sur et
public et protégée peu importe ce que tu
fais donc même si on a un ordre
professionnel devront passer légitime
sarasar en passant légitime exactement
maintenant pour ce qui est de la
pyramide de preuve en tout temps ball
c'est la rumeur la rumeur c'est quoi
saussez la personne a le même pas de
source avait même pas de références tdi
paraît que c'est si jamais vous allez
dans une cour de justice lui donnera il
paraît qu est coupable puis finalement
on sentit
sponsoring la rumeur c'est pas grand
chose juste au dessus on a le témoignage
le témoignage je le jure elle oui mini
parenthèse à quel point là on bosse
beaucoup des affaires qu'on dit sur la
rumeur
vraiment beaucoup quand tu croises le
témoignage je tiens juste à vous dire
quelque chose le podcast au complet son
témoignage mais oui maxence a donc c'est
pas c'est une très basses et sèches rêve
que je vous dis le d'abord nicole on est
juste au dessus la rumeur avait en plus
en plus puis encore encore pendant la
même limite l'autre parenthèse j'ai fait
avant c'est que moi je passe mon temps à
dire j'entends des gens dans ce vase un
podcast croix puis de l'utiliser comme
étant l'argument légitime mais si tu es
capable de retour de prêt alors que vous
avez apprécié les cavs a donné ses plus
de rues mal le tour c'est un témoignage
qu'on est capable d'avoir une référence
à sa sauce pas pareil sauf full tilt
témoignages qui ont la même valeur oui
au revoir donc d'alphand le témoignage
6ème temps
je vous dis que j'ai 20 $ dans mon
portefeuille le bâti mon témoignage on
peut dire qu'il pourrait être suffisant
parce qu'il ya quand même haute
probabilité que je viens dans l'ordre
dans mon portefeuille c'est pas une
pseudoscience quelconque et si jamais
c'est faux les conséquences ont pas de
tentera maintenant la conséquence est
que l'état mental ouais c'est ça les
conseils en section inventaire vous y
perdre quelque chose d'absolument
minimes m exactement ensuite on à
l'observation ce que vous observez
directement donc à maintenant si je vous
dis que j'ai une bague dans mon
portefeuille mais là c'est rare qu'on
une banque dans un portefeuille fait que
je pensais que
ses concurrents possibles il va falloir
que je vous donne un observations que
j'ai une bague dans mon portefeuille
je la refais j'avais pensé
juste au dessus de l'observation c'est
l'expérience expérience sait qu'on va
avoir des méthodes qui vont nous permet
de faire des mesures c'est nous qui
faisons l'expérience au dessus on a le
témoignage d'experts lié totu de nous
parce que lui l'expert il va être en
mesure d'avoir de meilleures méthodes
des méthodes beaucoup plus fiable que
nous donc il va être disons plus fiable
que si c'est nous qui a fait
l'expérience parce que lui vont être en
mesure de faire
péter des fois notre méthode on peut
penser qu'elle est bonne mais ça veut
pas dire qu'elle est vraiment bonne puis
l'expert peut nous corriger et c'est le
camp au dessus ça commence les études
scientifiques pourquoi l'étude et au
dessus de l'expert c'est que
l'étude à la revue par les pairs une
revue parler parce que c'est admettons
moi je publie un article sur les seuils
de publier un article sur les pissenlits
d'ailleurs l'excellent i dans un verre
d'eau de jeu c'est pourquoi avant de se
coucher il ya des experts qui sont
experts du pissenlit de la botanique et
qui sont experts de
sommeil peut-être que tu as dit au
niveau des muscles ou relaxation ok donc
maintenant un expert des muscles 1
botanique qui est un autre qui prêtent à
un mix des deux tutsi selon des mesures
bains où ils vont vérifier que les
méthodes son coeur est et c'est pour ça
qu'à l'étude et au dessus du témoignage
d'expert au dessus des études l'os étude
en double aveugle c'est à dire pourquoi
c'est en double avec c'est que ça
élimine des billets ter maintenant c'est
moi je fais une étude sur les
médicaments je veux que ça marche et je
fais pas une étude en espérant que le
médicament marchpole sais je veux
vraiment que ça fonctionne fake en
double aveugle élimine le fait que moi
je pourrais être biaisée à vouloir que
ça marche fixé à peut-être manipuler les
données puis je peux le faire
consciemment qui est de la fraude mais
je peux le faire inconsciemment qui est
involontaire mais au final bon ça marche
pourrait dans le cas de la colline le on
voulait que nos affaires fonctionnent
les bacs les études sur ce est à double
aveugle en fait parce que les fl ben
assad est pas parce que le coc vide ça
tellement une pandémie mondiale il
fallait aller vite hein donc you oui il
ya eu des études double aveugle et tous
et jusque là il fallait s'en tenir à qui
il faut faire l'étude là avec la plus
grande rigueur avec le peu de temps
qu'on ôte ici on sera admettons qu'on
s'était rendu compte que la copie dessus
et 99% de la planète le dégel qu'il
l'attrapait là il y aurait fallu aller
vite puis même si on avait eu un vaccin
qui avait pas été fait en double aveugle
un crime on l'aurait pris wascat 99% ça
aucun sens mais l'os c'est si ça tue 5 à
10% c'est dramatique pareil mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que peut-être que on
est capable de stopper un petit peu plus
la pandémie d'une certaine façon la
ralentir
pour qu'on soit en mesure d'avoir
vraiment vaccins des plus efficaces
possibles au titre on a l'âme et
analyses qui répertorie les études qui
ont été faites pour ça que la
méta-analyse est meilleur que les études
en double aveugle parce que aller
répertorie a livré le piaf et au christ
telles études n'étaient pas très bonnes
parce qu'elle a utilisé de l'affronter
l'étude on va l'éliminer parce que
peu importe que des billets ou qu'ils
aient joué
donc la méta-analyse c'est ce qui va
vraiment nous aider du moins en médecine
sur le sujet puis en haut on à la
théorie scientifique qui le consensus
scientifique défendant le consensus en
théorie m'intéressait
c'est la plus haute échelle de preuves
possibles si c'est le summum de la
meilleure représentation qu'on a de la
réalité terry d'évolution par exemple et
l'évolution théorie de la relativité
ça c'est vraiment c'est des théories en
théorie mais si on est tellement
certains épisodes dont le thème a prouvé
que finalement c'est vraiment une
certitude c'est pas une certitude
absolue mais c'est c'est assez démontré
qu' on est capable de faire confiance à
ses locaux à la lumière des informations
qu'on a eu deux depuis qu'on utilise un
petit scientifique cohérent on est rendu
le pipe la taille qu'un jour battront la
théorie de la relativité d'einstein ça
se peut qu'elle peut vraiment l'absolu
ça se peut qu'on veut mais pas parfaite
parce que la théorie de la relativité
monsieur remplacer celle de newton du
frais pour un cours de physique lé mal à
remplacer celle de newton ça veut pas
dire que celle de newton était
totalement fausse et est vrai jusqu'à un
certain point on se rendait compte y
avait peut-être des problèmes lorsqu'il
ya un bâton la distance était beaucoup
trop faible ou quelque chose comme ça
puis la relativité est arrivé puis
peut-être qu'un jour on va remplacer
cette série là en fait on voit la peau
fine et aux mollahs et là on voit plus
de précisions sur le sujet pour en
revenir aux pseudo science donc là j'ai
fait l'échelle de preuves la pseudo
science faites le si on vous présente
des témoignages qui est en bas de
l'échelle c'est un peu qu'est ce qu'on
dit l'une
c'est vraiment pas bon c'est
si c'est la parole d'un expert
bassiste en médecine c'est pas bon signe
non plus je vote quand je dis que c'est
pas bon signe c'est c'est la meilleure
source - si c'est la meilleure source
que tu es capable de prouver le monde
est encore bas dans l'échelle on est
encore bas dans l'échelle donc quand tu
te dis une étude sur dix patients mots
j'ai adoré tu dis ça parce qu une étude
dix patients thurien syrien sait
absolument rien des fois c'est la
meilleure source de preuve que toi c'est
ça des fois c'est la meilleure source de
preuve que toi le saviez est ce que tu
es prêt à faire confiance assurait ce
que tu acceptes laissons les rues quels
sont les risques est ce que tu es prêt à
tout dans le fond le pissenlit dans les
p o si ça le marché sur dix personnes
cela par conséquent j'ai pas de riscal
femme noire c'est sur exactement
je sais pas c'est quoi les
plus simples je vois
quelque chose qui ça peut nous amener
vers les biais cognitifs oui parce que
je trouvais ça super intéressant quand
tu parlais de ceux
dans les témoignages que tu disais je
t'ai entendu l'une des affaires les plus
vrai que j'avais jamais réfléchi puis
c'est qu'on a tout le temps le
témoignage du survivant je sais pas
comment tu de la pluie c'est mon préféré
c'est le
biais de survie le biais de survivants
qui corrige moi si je me trompe c'est
que tout le monde à qui on parle est un
survivant oui parce que les mots sont
morts c'est ça oh qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est que si elle met on vous aller
à l'épicerie pis bon vous avez un cancer
ça va pas bien il vous croisez quelqu'un
à l'épicerie et cette personne là vous
parle de jeu pour du pouvoir des
cristaux qu'à les utiliser avec je sais
pourquoi
pièce à la guérison elle ça le guéry son
cancer ce que en fait vous parlez à une
survivante ce que ça veut dire c'est que
y'a peut-être dix mille personnes qui
ont essayé son pouvoir des cristaux puis
il y en a peut-être 2009 cinq sont
décédés fait les 100 personnes qui
survivent c'est à eux qu'on parle on
parle pas aussi maintien décédé parce
que justement ils sont décédés donc on
parle toujours aux survivants de la
pseudo science qu'on convoi et puis si
on l'appliqué même encore une fois tout
ce qu'on dit tantôt si vraiment
facilement applicables à la situation là
que vite parce que là on l'a vu
maintenant si le nombre de personnes non
de personnes sans nommer personne qui
dit j'ai guéri la kfw d'acoz que j'ai
pris tel lui elle est essentielle de
lavande pique au final il ya du monde
qui ont pris celle là qui sont pas
guéries de la cabine double sens ont
permis aussi rapidement ccrb l'on parle
à la personne la personne qui lapide
qu'ils en parlent ils un plus c'est sûr
en parler mais l'envié je veux dire
quelque chose d'encore surtout c'est une
maladie qui revient c'est que west gate
pour venir par toi même s'arrêter oui
ben en fait c'est un peu ce que j'avais
écrit et
le taux de survie et emmène très élevé
même pour des gens qui sont pas soignés
ce que je veux dire nous on est quand
même plus jeunes le fax est possible que
si on pogne l'aco vide sait
on ce que je conçois que ça se peut
qu'on décide mais dans le sens qu'il ya
de bonnes chances que on soit correcte
mais si la meute on a utilisé l'élixir
de chez paco el ok puis on dit ah j'ai
guéri mais en fait si moutons faisait
une étude sur cette élection le puis on
prend justement dix mille personnes si
on dit aux gens
9950 qui ont survécu y en eu 50 qui sont
décédés ok mais le saut sur j pour ça
aussi c'est le pourcentage la cave il
savait pas dit que ton produit marche
mais si on ne sent pour cinq sont roque
même si on a 100 % qui sont totalement
guéris peut-être qu'on va se rendre
compte ok mais qui a utilisé ses selon
eux c'est tout des gens qui sont dans la
vingtaine ok - mais ceux qui sont dans
la vingtaine je veux pas être plantes
mais ces signes ont plus de chances de
guérir la cabine mais alors que si les
matons des gens qui ont 80 90 1 okello
ce que ça change la balance donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aussi voir les
patients les personnes qui ont participé
mais le biais de survivance est ce qu'on
parle toujours où survivaient on a parlé
du prieuré tantôt il ya des gens au
début de la colline que et on dit que la
prière aller les sauver ben il y en a
beaucoup qui sont décédés de ce qui émet
de la prière sont pas décidés de la
claque au vide malgré le fait qu'ils ont
probablement prier mais ils sont décédés
fait qu'on en entend plus parler mais on
entend parler de ceux qui ont prié et
qui sont sur les lieux
voilà c'est ça c'est ça le biais de son
rival est ce que
vivre ou mourir il est une métaphore
c'est vraiment littéralement le biais de
survivance élise en kimono mythe c'est
une métaphore mais là ça s'applique
beaucoup et le
le fait de mourir ou pas je vous donne
un autre exemple
les toques les têtes comme friends c'est
des survivants ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que les
les personnes qui vont
faire des conférences ted c'est des gens
qui ont pensé au travers du système que
ça adonne qui ont peut-être un compte je
suis un survivant en venant ici je suis
un survivant venant ici vous avez
accepté le fait que c'est justement
avant un pays en cours hier c'est
peut-être ça pourrait vous intéresser
qu'on ne vous auriez pu dire non il ya
peut-être plein d'autres mondes qui nous
écoutent en ce moment qui ont fait des
choses très intéressantes à dire et puis
qui sont paul moi je suis un survivant
jeu sans vie en venant ici donc oui on
peut voir ça comme une métaphore parce
que ça c'est en beaucoup plus large que
ceux ci seront moi je le reste tient
surtout à la pseudo science et la
médecine parallèle le concept dont le
plus facile à exprimer mais oui tu as
raison ça peut s'appliquer à plaindre
autre chose
c'est quoi un billet culture en biais
cognitif c'est un raccourci que notre
cerveau fait puis en a des centaines
le j'en ai parlé un petit peu en tôle
mais le biais de confirmation il est pas
mal un des plus intenses qu'on peut
avoir le biais de confirmation c'est
plusieurs choses c'est aller en me
trompant ce quelque chose c'est allé
voir les informations qui confirment ce
qu'on pense c'est lorsqu'on a plusieurs
types d'informations qu'on a on va
privilégier les informations qui
confirment ce qu'on pense qu'on va
considérer que c'est plus sont plus
imposante et les arguments qui confirme
ce qu'on pense aux plus forts que les
arguments qui sont moins forts si on y
va avec j'avais donné l'exemple je
pensais le confinement ceux qui ont
qu'ils veulent on social ben ils vont
aller voir les gens qui pensent comme
eux ils vont aller voir au québec moi je
veux continuer à faire du social je vais
pas porter le masque bâton je veux pas
pour tellement ça me tente pas porter le
masque parfait je m'envoie chercher les
informations que respaud parfait tu vas
chercher les informations qu'ils pensent
que moi que le masaï leur garde sur tel
site web tel blog et telle chose que ou
ameutant on parlait de l'homéopathie
le motton il ya 100 études qui disent
que l'homéopathie fonctionne pas pièce
inquiétudes qui disent que ça fonctionne
ben moi je vends vote montre prendre les
5 et 8 jean ferrat il ya cinq études qui
fonctionne mais cherry picking et envoie
chercher les laits la donne et qui va
confirmer reconfirmer ce que tu veux
croire ce que tu veux croire mais il ya
plein de choses comme ça au niveau des
billets cognitif le biais de survivants
le biais de confirmation il est entre
autres parlé de témoignages aussi
j'aimerais sans qu'ils aient souvent
mettons mettons je vois quelque chose de
bizarre dans le ciel le plus souvent ça
s'arrêtait ce puits mettant quelqu'un
télé raconte quelque chose de bizarre
dans ciel c'est vrai qu'il veut quelque
chose de bizarre dans ciel puis cette
partie de son témoignage tu peux le
croire maintenant mais souvent c'est la
conclusion qui va en tirer une chose
bizarre leur ciel donc
on dirait que souvent si on on est très
mauvais à faire les bonnes conclusions
aux prévisions qui sont complètement
saugrenue oui exact que la personne qui
croit que c'est une soucoupe volante
aveux c'est ce à quoi le terrain avec ce
serait le fun le progrès elle moi
j'aimerais seul mais ça serait vraiment
cool mais adapte les informations on y
en aurait pas mais c'est exactement ce
que tu dit et je vois quelque chose dans
ciel me tombe moi je te dis lg j'ai vu
quelque chose dans le ciel je suis sûr
que c'est une soucoupe à nantes je crois
vraiment que c'est une soucoupe volante
toi ta connaissance et que tu sais que
moi je t'ai dit que j'ai vu une soucoupe
volante reposer que ce qu'on voit là
mais l'élève tu peux me croire mais
probablement que soit être sceptique sur
le sujet vous êtes quoi que tu as vu
quelque chose qui était pas
d'ailleurs l'an passé pour ce qui est
des êtres capables de retrouver monte à
la première source la soucoupe volante
sa date des années 40 c'est un pilote
d'avion qu'il ya vu quelque chose dans
le ciel puis ça aurait pu être des pays
tiers à la république n'a pas de quoi
puis le journaliste écrit fleig sens sa
partie de
limousis clip best
way mais pour ce qui est des biais
cognitif long on peut vraiment vraiment
c'est quoi les plus courants maintenant
parce que moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est quelque chose qui vraiment courant
dans notre société oki bien de
confirmation est très courant le biais
de surivants moi c'est que je laime bois
je dirais négligence la taille de
l'échantillon est assez énorme aussi ce
que je veux dire c'est que admettons et
j'avais vu quelqu'un qui s'était fait
des tos le matin que le pire était
peut-être le matin mais il s'est fait
des choses qu'il y avait un visage
dessus puis à des gens qui croient à ces
que servir je me la vierge marie ou
jésus ou peu importe le
yari racheter pour 28 mai le dolent srib
et 7 ans le saas est une négligence de
l'appareil de les chantiers c'est quoi
la probabilité que nous trois lothion
substance le matin puis qu'est un visage
dessus est extrêmement faible fin mai
des milliards de tous qui ont chacune
est donc fait que c'est quoi la
probabilité qu'il y en ait une là-dedans
keller de d'abord un visage de suisse
tremont norme c'est énorme puis on a de
la difficulté à être capable de
percevoir sauter c'est incroyable il ya
eu telle chose c'est quoi la probabilité
que que moi je gagne le gros lot à la
laiterie pour zéro parce que j'achète
pas de bien mais maintenant
c'est très très faible mais c'est quoi
la probabilité que quelqu'un gagne le
gros lot à la truite extrait pour ce
mois ci c'est vrai que ça c'est la
négligence la taille de l'échantillon et
on va en faire vraiment on va faire ça
sur les cadrages non pas cadrage offert
l'ancrage hockey le biais d' ancrage si
admettons le je vous pose une question
avec un chiffre puis
ensuite je vous pose une autre question
reliée à cette même question là le
chiffre va avoir une influence sur votre
réponse ce que je veux dire c'est que si
je vous dis que la baleine bleue est ce
que la baleine bleue mesure 500 miles
ok combien mesurait la baleine bleue
dans les études ayant et ont montré que
ça les gens répondent et je pensais en
moyenne 180 mais
si on me disait est ce qu'une baleine
bleue mesure 3 cm mais non pour 3
centimes en une semaine trop petits ont
bien besoin le 18 mai coin le premier
chiffre a une influence sur le
la réponse est ce que ça fait c'est
calme et au vous avez une maison avant à
tous et je vous donne un prix d'abord
vous mettons vous voulez acheter la
maison que je vous donne un prix d'abord
avons 300 milles maintenant si tu me la
fais à 250 doit être contente ouais bon
et inversement et inversement si je vous
donne pas de prix ça se peut que vous
ayez un choix de chez denon beaucoup
plus précis que ce que c'était que si je
vous avais pas nommé chief même si est
exagéré admettons je dis ma maison moi
je les verts pour 1 5 million rythme
trop élevé combien tu veux l'acheter
450000 on est bon on est loin des 300
milles le temps dolby plus le chiffre
est précis plus l'ancrage et fort c'est
pour ça que dans les boutiques c'est pas
50 dollars c'est 49,99
parce que à 49 99 ans ça doit coûter 1
peut-être 42 43 pièces ça coûtait 50 on
dirait qu ils l'ont augmentée de même la
plus le chiffre est précis plus
l'ancrage efforts et ça va vous
influencer fac si jamais vous avez à
négocier soyez le 1er à 10 ans est pris
à deux reprises
puis millions d'euros
[Rires]
c'est une maison leur aspect haute au
détail le tu veux juste dire 300
1997 et 92 violent le biais de cadrage
que génome un peu c'est maintenant vous
avez une photo ya une photo qui est très
populaire
sais tu vois un soldat américain il me
semble que c'est un soldat irakien et
deux soldats américains il y en a un qui
fait boire de l'eau puis l'autre comme
un
mitrailleuses sur la tête fax ictu cadre
que c'est juste celui que mitraillant tu
vois les américains contre le soldats
iraniens titi on peut faire dire
n'importe quoi cette photo l'obs du cas
de l'autre à regarder comme avec le
soldat américain est fait c il faut
vraiment faire à temps sion lors
lorsqu'on a par exemple au niveau des
médias le cadrage est vraiment important
pee wee et en a qui vont encadrer moi ça
peut faire du sensationnel et c'est tout
fini il y avait une arrivée ne pas
l'aimer clé que c'était aux états unis
puis c'était comme des jeunes trump
heist le pied dans la vidéo tu voyez
avec la de smokey des premières nations
des gens première nation j'ai fait fait
un tollé le monde avait dit le tipi le
sait qu'ils au pire on veut leur nom
pions et ils peuvent vraiment comment on
détruit steiger finalement le
jeu vidéo en dessous des sorties après
piste et pas du tout sinon
on peut faire une recherche par image
le ton dépendamment de
des sites que deux pas des sites des
logiciels que vous utilisez pour aller
sur internet
vous pouvez faire une recherche par
images que vous êtes capable de
retourner ou l'image a commencé les
premières dit des fois pour voir une
image dit un peu importe le
seul exemple que j'ai en tête c'est une
fausse croyance comme que les humains il
y était grand de 10 mais tout doucement
était urgent 5000 m
puis dans le fond la photo c'est tout ce
que tu vois ce temps j'ai un cador tu
vois un monsieur qui est de boucler la
hausse y le crâne tabarouette ok de
recherche par image plus c'était un
concours de photoshop
hockey parce que ce sans
jamais vous ne croirez jamais l'acteur
mort qui en gaspésie en fin de semaine
si la photo date de 1990
[Rires]
donc biais cognitifs il peut en avoir
vraiment beaucoup je dirais le biais de
confirmation est probablement un des
plus puissants parce que puis quand je
dis ça le petit jeu des mots si je suis
victime de soldes c'est ce pas parce que
je lui mais c'est bien d'en avoir
conscience pour mieux les contrer ça
aussi c'est pour ce jeu les demandes et
celui sur les probabilités que tu
parlais l'exemple avec la touche le
point négligence devant un chantier puis
si on prend les ovnis le type
dernièrement il y avait comme sortie des
vidéos le des d'objets volants non
identifiés qu'avec les prix par par des
censeurs de la remettrai mais les
censeurs de l'armée
il ya tout le temps qu'ils prennent des
images en continu sans arrêt fait que
les chances quand niang soit défaillant
qui calcule mal une vitesse ou quoi que
ce soit qui sont énormes l'eau ils font
le tri puis que le fait qu'on a juste
quelques joints quelques vidéos de venir
qu'ils soient sortis depuis le temps
mais c'est quasiment c'est que je n'en
ai souvent c'est tellement fou qui en a
juste quelques années d'expérience comme
ça ou alors l'argument en plus des gens
qui croient dur comme fer si il ya trop
d'occasions que trop de gens qui ont vu
des a failli être ou de vidéos contraire
c'est sa conjointe films ou des gens qui
voient des choses il ya en a des
milliards à chaque jour oui c'est
bien fait c'est pas parce qu'on a deux
cent mille témoignages de personnes qui
ont vu un ovni que les ovnis
exact donc on est encore au témoignage
demandé en bas de l'échelle on est
d'accord en pis bon il y en a qui vont
dire ils veulent nous cacher mais j'ai
posé qui il veut
singer pages bien de penser un biais
cognitifs qui est peut-être je veux pas
des plus forts mais les concepts ont
parlé des conséquences l'effet de halo
et fédérales hausse et que met-on
l'apparence physique d'une personne le
contenu du tout que le contenu va avoir
une influence sur ce qu est ce qu on
repensait ils y ont fait certaines
études c'est assez dramatique cela ils
ont mis à des membres de jury ou quelque
chose comme ça au niveau de la justice
le même texte mais ils ont changé la
photo de la personne et selon
l'attirance physique ça change et cela
personne était coupable ou innocent ça
change et même sa pin donc l'effet d'un
lourd se passe ça pourrait être vraiment
les conserver nos préjugés là il faut
c'est bien d'avoir conscience des fois
de nos préjugés pour essayer de
suspendre notre jugement pour essayer de
contrer notre propre confirmation finale
même si des préjugés positif oui envers
quelqu'un sait maintenant que ce soit
quelqu'un qui rend dans une pièce qui
est vraiment une belle prestance pis qui
s'exprime bien il faut être capable de
dire cette personne à qui ça c'est le
logis majine de la personne qui le met
ça veut pas dire que les informations
qui me transmet sont légitimes ben en
fait le on rentre dans un sujet plus
intense mais jeudi le recrutement de
sectes qui peut se faire comme ça quand
tu dois être très gentil il vraiment
très gentil pour se rendre compte plus
tard que jeudi une secte mais ça peut
être une pseudoscience le ca peut être
ce
jeudi si si je réussis à de vendre mes
affaires puis je réussis encore attendre
la tangente en demande stable c'est pas
parce que je suis gentil que ce que je
te propose c'est vrai donc c'est pour ça
que les faits dans la loire mais il est
tellement enfin thème admettons le que
je tente sans dessein arrogante
dégueulasse ce que je dis ça peut être
réparée c'est moi que ce soit ici mais
si je suis super fin vous croyez à mes
jeux pour pc sur les élections qui ont
été trouvés ce sommet de montagne en
chine
c'est pas parce que je suis gentil
qu'est ce que je vous propose c'est vrai
notre point que je dirais qui pourrait
peut-être avoir un lien avec les faits
d'or nous faudrait janvier jordi qui
tenus dans l'ariège le pas sur le banc
mais tous les quartiers des choses de
front serait
si justement les listings de devenir le
tipi georges écouter un reportage je
peux savoir ce que y aller il ya la
rencontre et deux grecs mettant aux
autres le vin est un et on fait un
emprunt qui l'a le village dans lequel
il habitait puis on fait chauffer
l'espèce de ballons avec pi lumineux et
puis on fait monter sedan hockey pilotes
montent ils m'ont en fait c'est quoi
sopi le retour de la main et vous soyez
reçoivent l'y appelait la radio il ya eu
ce pays continue à en faire ce qu'ils
ont fait est souvent
rapidement
c'est comme si la légende des passes oui
rapidement ce qui s'était passé
brièvement qui disaient oh j'en ai vu à
partir des 300 km/h c'était c'est
vraiment juste débattez comme cela c'est
comme le mien si les hommes étaient dans
des eaux plus le monde
j'hérite c'est devenu une grosse affaire
le cadre
puis finalement non comme des
mannequins qui ont dit qu
il ya des gens qui ont dit non non c'est
vraiment les pieds vous dites je sais
pas ce que vous vous êtes dit de dire si
en fait j'ai trois
femmes c'est exactement la même histoire
pour le monstre du loch ness
mais semble c'est exactement la même
chose que le la réalité a dépassé la
fiction que c'est des gens qui ont
inventé sur mech finalement et en a
tellement qui ont dit qu'ils ont vu et
atteint
les têtes de tellement de choses
le monstre du loch ness de parler
réalité dépasse la fiction
quand l'hymne à savoir mener c'est que
je n'ai pas d'aimer t'il pas des mythes
qui seront en tous cas nous le tri même
nous mettons des mythes plus je peux
entrer dans les polémiques métier
méthodes et des histoires bibliques ou
la faire de même
des fois même ils se rendent compte que
j'avais vraiment un événement historique
meetic après cela distorsion que eu dans
le recomptage et après si ça a été et
qui métier on était déjà rendu bien plus
ct boulonnais biais cognitif du faux
souvenirs ça même été testée hier
ils ont organisé un moment donné j'ai vu
un étudiant organisé une émission
quelconque pourquoi on n'apprend pas
toutes les mêmes rend pas les billets
canadiens
allez
vas-y
faux souvenirs de pillon mis un poster
avec une petite fille tout en ayant fait
les missions complètes ayant questionné
les gens quelques mois plus tard puis on
dit oui qui avait l'eau
près par pilote les gens il y en a qui
ont dit oui à 26 filles je les ai vus à
jouer à terre mais ces imposteurs est un
affichage de rien le pilote qu'on leur
montrait vidéo de dire regardez c'était
juste une affiche c'est en biais
cognitifs du faux sur néon puis la
personne elle est follement doué mais tu
es convaincu est ce vraiment à pense
avoir vu une petite fille mais c'est un
faux souvenirs à caroline c'est pas ce
qui s'est passé c'est autre chose donc
la forme attendue tu agis me rappeler la
troisième chose que je voulais dire
les pour ce qu'il m'a tant du monde du
loch ness ou ce que te dis les soucoupes
volantes mais y'en a
qui ont eu un faux souvenirs de trous
qui ont peut-être vu juste un petit
enfant qui ont considéré ont pensé tout
de suite à la conclusion pour se dire
que c'est pour ce qui est des crops gros
ce que tu sais ce que tu te dis qu'ils
ont fait un principe mais en fait les
serres de culture il y en a qui ont fait
des cercles de culture c'est à dire ils
prennent une planche décor pif ils font
des genres de cercle dans des champs de
l'île ce qui est pas très gentil pour
les agriculteurs puis quand qu'il
revendique et le fait que tu es heureux
il y avait aucune polémique avait rien
personne qui dit qu'ils allaient prier
en plein milieu du kop s'y colle pour
dire que c'était des aliens fac leur et
avait conduit ben on dira pas que chez
nous enfin que lyon reddick c'est une
fête maintenant pour eux ils trouvent
que c'est une oeuvre dans vous irez voir
serial killer le tueur de céréales
céréales qu'elle a le choix de séries en
fac les dix pages dis pas que c'est moi
parce que quand je dis que c'est moi et
personne qui vient père si on n'en parle
pas radio incorpore journal mais quand
j'avais quand je dis pas que c'est moi
y'en a plein qui pensent que c'est les
aliens sont venus fait quelques achats
d'énergie va
bien dans une coupe qui ont fait vous
irez voir astronomiques c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait un crop ce record avec
d'autres sceptiques
pillon rien dit avant quelques semaines
puis c'était pour tester ce qui les
experts qui disent que c'est dès
qu'ils sont des experts qui disent que
c'est des hellions et puis évidemment ça
marche pas parce qu'ils se savent bien
les autres le
le faux souvenirs là ça nous arrive même
aux cds fois des foyers comme une
histoire ti cats quand état que des gens
depuis longtemps dans ta vie puis qu'est
ce qui s'est réellement passé tu te
raconte l'histoire et à chaque fois que
tu te raconte l'histoire il comme tu es
comme juste un tout petit peu à côté
l'histoire sa peur il est là un tout
petit peu à côté puis un tout petit peu
à côté plus ça fait quand même
l'histoire quand tu es rendu elle a
raconté que la santé monsieur des
histoires qu'on raconte tout le temps
tandja reconnaît la centième fois ça pue
de livres avec la mort comme des coqs
est complètement différent sauf que est
un mythe de fait le trajet avec
l'histoire de fois en fois elle s'est
rendue sur ton sur ton souvenir c'est
plus de des autres fautes raconter
l'histoire que de souvenirs d'origine
ouais ouais effectivement sans le biais
cognitifs c'est au souci il y avait un
test super facile aussi je vous nommez
je vous nomme 120 mo qui ont un lien
avec le sommeil puis après je vous nomme
des mots dites moi si ça faisait partie
des mots puis locaux d'itway puis en
adac ne
soumettons qu'ils ont de nouveau subi
son alya que le sommet doit peut-être
plus être portée en fait c'est
exactement parce que maintenant raconte
une histoire que l'on ne véhiculent mmt
ans on était dans une soirée on peut
importe puisque tu racontes aux deux
parties de l'histoire le mans je fais
moi mais moi je me rappelle plus de
telles choses ah oui ok puis le sait
c'est comme ça se forge un peu puis ses
souvenirs et ses
fous pareils puis
toutes ces choses le qui comme je disais
en parant tantôt sont pas enseignées t
on on les apprend pau puis ça nous
permet pas de d'être outillés puis armé
contre
comme défaut d'arguments l'enfant contre
les forces nouvelles et rumeurs
sur toi c'est une des raisons pourquoi
tu as décidé de commencer ton 2eme donc
voir j'ai appris la science maintenant
ben en fait je me suis vraiment
intéressé je m'intéresse à comprendre le
monde puis la philosophie est vraiment
c'est vraiment très en lien avec la
science y en a qui font même pas de
distinction entre les deux ferrari ce
que j'aime beaucoup une somme y avait
mentionné la philosophie c'est des
expériences de pensée et puis quand tu
es capable de faire des vraies
expériences sur le terrain c'est la
science mais les deux c'est la même
chose donc c'est des méthodes
rationnelles pour comprendre le monde
moche j'ai j'ai vu un moment d un débat
entre cyrille barrette et un
créationniste cyrille barrette et un
professeur retraité de mercy laval
experts la théorie de l'évolution puis
il ya juste dix à l'entrevue
on le présentait monsieur à ma gauche
croit à la création monsieur ma droite
croit la révolution puis cyrille
barrette a juste dit je vous prendre
pour ce que vous avez dit au début les
créationnistes croit la création mais
les évolutionnistes europe on ne pas
croire à l'évolution connaît l'évolution
en croit le savoir il ya une énorme
différence moi ça m'a assommé pin le puy
ce temps là la philosophie m'a vraiment
intéressé soit l'épistémologie
l'épistémologie ce que c'est c'est
comment on crée de la connaissance c'est
quoi les méthodes pour acquérir des
connaissances puis évidemment la science
en fait partie donc je me suis vraiment
intéressé à ce puits par la bande c'est
là que j'ai appris c'était quoi la
pensée critique ce texte et costa fun je
connaissais même pas sûr je n'étais pas
cours en sciences moi j'ai jamais ta
propre aux anars pas le raisonnement de
la pensée claire c'est non on a pris un
bain dans le fond n'a pas de cours de
sureau considère dans blick tulle après
mais c'est pas enseigner on n'a pas de
cours d'épistémologie on n'a pas de
courant de pensée critique de pensée
rationnelle du moins pour moi ce que
j'ai fait est ce que ça a changé depuis
le temps moi j'ai pas vu que ça change
rien de cool mais ya rien de plus ça m'a
vraiment intéressé puis la directrice d
expérience m'a dit écoute coup-de-poing
dr au pot si tu t'intéresses vraiment
faire la distinction de croyance et
connaissances en épistémologie ge ben
pourquoi pas est-ce que d'étudier la
philosophie épistémologie au renfort
émettons à foix qui en la méthode
scientifique par la science où tu es
plus critiques allant voir mettons
certains procédés si on fait en fait je
dirais que j'en ai plus appris sur la
science en étudiant en philosophie puis
je suis content d'avoir fait ça parce
qu'avant je
l'appliqué sens mais sans m'être posé la
question pourquoi un peu comme si on
apprend que la terre est ronde on s'est
jamais posé la question comment
conjuguer terrain donc pour renforcer ma
foi j'ai pas à dire que je crois en la
science la science
et mais je dirais que la pensée critique
m'a amené à être beaucoup plus critique
envers tout sur tout ce que je pense sur
tout ce qui est dans ma tête parce que
je me suis rendu compte que c'est quand
qu'on ait biaisé on s'étonne serment que
les pirates où sont les tous le jeudi je
suis jean c'est sur l'austisme
probablement que des gens qui vont nous
écoutent et puis qui va retenir notre
attention tu as été un peu trop loin là
tu puisses c'est très possible mais moi
ce que j'aime c'est que je me dis je
suis prêt à me dis que j'ai eu tort tout
ce qui a trait à la valeur de la vérité
je suis prêt à changer d'avis on est
capable de me démontrer que j'ai eus
temps je veux changer d'avis upi je
pense c'est ce que la philosophie m'a
amené c'est vraiment être critique
envers tous incluant la science mais
vraiment tout ce qui a trait à la vérité
tout qu'est-ce qu'une valeur de vérité
l'on peut emmener à la pensée critique
l' je pense que c'est le concerne a
lille
la pensée critique c'est quoi ya pas de
définition universelle la pensée
critique fait que je vais vous en donner
trop en philosophie c'est surtout basé
sur l'argumentation l'argumentation sais
c'est quoi les vérités c'est quoi les
énoncés qui sont vrais et c'est quoi les
liens logiques quand des énoncés penser
de manière rationnelle on peut voir ça
comme ça
pour ce qui est de critical thinking de
la bns aux états unis lui c'est sais pas
qu'est ce que la pensée critique mais
qu'est ce que ça prend pour être un
penseur critique savait quels sont les
habilités que quelqu'un doit avoir pour
en être pensez à critiquer doit
suspendre son jugement il doit penser de
manière réfléchie doit pas aller à des
conclusions trop hâtives donc l'approché
vraiment différent mais on voit que
quand même un certain lien la troisième
que j'aime beaucoup ça vient surtout de
henry broc de en france normand
baillargeon ici en philosophie
christophe michel thomas durand de la
tronche en biais c'est la pensée
critique c'est un filtre qui permet de
distinguer le vrai du faux puis se fit
le on peut utiliser des outils le je me
lance quels sont les outils de la pensée
critique en a beaucoup
premièrement la balance de siegen la
balance de ces jeunes c'est la personne
qui fait une affirmation elle doit avoir
des preuves qui pèse aussi lourde que
son affirmation autrement dit une
affirmation extraordinaire requiert des
preuves extraordinaires dit la pyramide
qu'on a vu tantôt si on donne et
témoignages là c'est le vin et pias que
dans mon portefeuille ça vaut mais si on
parle d'un élixir qui est capable de
guérir du cancer même unité même si vous
avez un cancer que vous prenez mon
élection et que vous vous êtes guéri ce
sera pas suffisant parce que je dis que
s'il n'y a pas des guérites ou les
cancers l'exemple du donnait c'est pour
quelque chose de super anodin comme il
ya des grenouilles sur mon terrain oui
un témoignage c'est suffisant
ça s'adresse en campagne puis le
témoignage des lieux des grenouilles sur
mon terrain je suis en par contre si je
dis il ya des
j'ai vu un kangourou sur mon terrain
croit sa section hockey comme un aspect
plus qu'un témoignage et c'est avec un
gourou à verdon
[Musique]
qui ont prouvé que des kangourous à ckoi
ordi dans versus extraordinaire ben
c'est quoi la probabilité que ça arrive
ouais mais ton c'est quoi si je prédis
qu'il va avoir une tempête de neige en
janvier au québec c'est la soeur dit
dans les bonnes chances que ça arrive au
pire j'aurai demande si ces gens mais si
je dis que demain il va avoir une
explosion volcanique à sept îles je suis
mieux d'amener de pas mal de données
parce que la dernière explosion
volcanique qui a eu au québec la date de
quoi centaines de millions d'années
c'est chez mieux d'amener beaucoup de
choses extraordinaires on peut voir ça
comme est-ce que ça arrive souvent s'il
arrive pas souvent c'est très
extraordinaire donc ça c'est le premier
outil que jamais un deuxième le renfort
des jeunes c'était une combinaison de
deux choses la première c'est
la charge de la preuve incombe à celui
qui affirme autrement dit c'est moi je
dis que je crois au fait que je crois
aux lutins c'est à moi de prouver que
les faits ou les lutins existe c'est pas
à vous de prouver que ça existe pas de
façon prouver quelque chose n'existe pas
c'est difficile
pour prouver que les corbeaux noirs
existent on a juste à trouver un corbeau
noir puis ça prouve que ça et quand on
regarde le regarda titre mais pour
prouver que les dragons n'existe pas il
faut quasiment brouillé l'univers entier
pour savoir si c'est ça qui fait qu'on
voit c'est plus beaucoup plus facile à
trouver en fait l'existence qu'elle
emploiera dont il nous a même façon dans
son repaire du monde son butin midi le
dragon qui est des ragots il avec
l'argument de tabasco n'ai jamais vu que
ça existe pause pauvreté en france non
c'est vraiment pas facile ce fils de la
baleine
si puissamment il l'autre point des
rasoirs des deux chaînes c'est si jamais
quelqu'un vous arrive avec une
affirmation
sans preuve ben vous pouvez jeter son
affirmation sans preuve autrement dit
quelqu'un qui dit
que les vaccins c'est pour nous injecter
une puce qu'on retour d'être contrôlé
par 2,5 g au gouvernement ben
non
kamada me prouver non pardon
voilà c'est exactement ce qui amène des
preuves ce sont des enfants mais si elle
mène à rien ben vous pouvez les acheter
semprun aux tutsis le prince est
attention biais cognitifs du retour de
flamme
retour de floch et le joueur
parenthèse bien cognitif du retour de
flamme ouais c'est pas exactement ça si
jamais vous amener des arguments
rationnels envers quelqu'un de si des
faits pour prouver que ce qu'ils
avancent c'est faux il ya des bonnes
chances qu'ils croient encore plus à ce
qu'ils pensent ouais
citons un biais cognitifs de retour de
france mène donc 1 - ch je crois
vraiment qu'on est contrôlé par l'a5
jury si vous menez des arguments
rationnels que non à meudon on n'a pas
réussi à construire de puces c'est
impossible on sait même pas d'où émerge
la conscience fait que quand même on est
capable de contrôler quelqu'un peu
importe moi je vois est encore plus
renforcée à croire qu'on vaut avoir
qu'on est contrôlé par le singe et que
c'est fou
mais pierre bleue s'est basé sur trois
choses mais ça manque de confiance en
soi
l'émotion puis un autre à faire l'étude
juin
je veux qu'on continue oui les outils
les outils sauf que tantôt je veux qu'on
revienne aussi sur
comment avoir une discussion parfait
croyances on va parler de conversation
va parler de parfaits on va continuer un
petit peu avec les outils c'est
fascinant quand les outils est à mathon
je vous dis où je me rappelle avoir vu
soit trois fois maintenant je vous dis
il ya des loups qui ont trouvé un enfant
à très bas âge et que
l'on éduque les enfants c'est un gros
mot le même temps ils ont nourri les
enfants ils ont vraiment nourrir les
enfants puis on peut presque dire qu'ils
ont éduqué le jeu vous proches de la
question
selon vous qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans
la tête de ces loulous peu importe le
maintenant répondu ce que vous voulez
mais il y a un outil qui s'appelle le
principe de fresnel c il faut mettre en
évidence un phénomène avant d'en
rechercher les côtes ce que ça veut dire
c'est quand vous posant cette question
de je viens de vous considérer d'emblée
qu'il ya des enfants qui ont été élevé
par des loups alors qu'il faudrait
vérifier d'abord si ce que je dis est
vrai c'est à dire s'il est lui s'il ya
des enfants qui ont vraiment été élevé
par des loups puis après on se posera la
question c'est quoi qui est en tête des
looney musicologique ça arrive des fois
qu'on va poser une question comme seule
table les prémices sont peu déprimé
ces professions sont pas vérifiés c'est
sur exactement c'est plus dix qui sont
pas vérifiés puis un petit dernier pour
la route le rasoir d'occam sait il faut
pas multiplier les entités sans
nécessiter ce que ça veut dire c'est que
si on a plusieurs hypothèses pour un
certains phénomènes mettons la
construction des pyramides il y en a qui
disent que c'est des éoliennes
pierre attendent autrement dire c'est
des humains dont moi
il faut prendre les hypothèses les plus
vraisemblables d'abord ça a été
construit par des humains et si jamais
on a des preuves que ça pourrait avoir
qu'ont été conçues par des
extraterrestres l'on changera d'avis ça
sert à rien de commun d'abord une
explication surnaturel si on a une
explication naturelle dans le capable
d'expliquer le terme et on on dit aussi
extraordinaire que les pyramides ont été
construits par des êtres humains mais
c'est encore plus extraordinaire que
c'était construit par des
extraterrestres
existent ou un autre exemple quand vous
êtes dans votre lit à 00h30 le votre
maison chèque avec un gros bruit que
vous entendez ce soit vous entendez un
certain bruit le film ok qu'est ce que
ça peut être ça peut être le vin sprit
le tonnerre puis ça peut être un trouble
dorthe qui parle passer par le avec
gandalf en arrière mais c'est les
urugayens c'est les urugayens
même pas été prouvées ont infecté c'est
une chance sur un tremblement de terre
ce qui serait extraordinaire ce qui ce
qui est déjà extraordinaire extrêmement
ce soit les mocassins ou
je suis pas tim et on te parle de leur
mettons stonehenge puis encaissés sur cd
à l'ouverture pourquoi des humains est
construite mais pourquoi les liens
avaient construit
encore
en passer yockey j'ai vu que j'ai faut
que je pense et critique faut vérifier
si ce que je dirais mais il me semble
avoir vu en vidéo de quelqu'un que
construit l'équivalent de stone age seul
à 0
avec les technologies de l'époque on
utilisait un principe de la ville me
semble ça a été très long on construit
c'est une double promesse sans principes
de la vie qui utilisent mais voudraient
vérifier c'est justement le titre c'est
tellement les pyramides de l'été c'est
tellement une oeuvre massive c'est
vraiment impressionnant que l'être
humain ont réussi à faire ce que moi
mettons je le vois plus dans le sens
nice veut voir
comment tout s'est articulée à place de
la place de comme madame c'est sur ce
post c'est sûr chez les alliés même plus
dangereux aliens a réussi parce que
c'est plus le fun ii se dit que c'est
des humains parce qu'on s'intéresse à
ces gamins qui ont fait pas besoin de
les pyramides et juste le colisée de
rome sans aide ans à l'époque l'est
tabarouette ses 14 puis josé iddac
mayette encore le riz pour totalement la
meilleure on a des ruines délais des
partis qui est encore le manquer donc si
j'avais à dire ceux c'est soit on a
parlé tantôt mais vérifier la qualité de
la source de l'information remonter à la
première source on ne parle un petit peu
tantôt l'autre 6 tient un blog sur
facebook c'est un article scientifique
l'échelle des preuves aussi donc donc je
pense que je me sens déjà plus outillé
france que l'on qui nous écoutent aussi
hélas une fois une fois qu'on en arrive
avec
la capacité ajustements
savoir ce qui est une croyance puis
d'être capable de discerner les bonnes
informations défaut ce cas qu'on est
confronté à quelqu'un pour qui la
croyance puis on le fait en ce moment je
pense que ça jamais été aussi clair
qu'aujourd'hui
maintenant l'heure des gens dans notre
entourage des amis qui finalement ont
une croyance qui pas basée sur la
science sauf qu'on sent que ce sujet
leur peut pas être abordée parce qu' ils
soient savent à renfoncer la personne
dans sa croyance l'éloigner de la vérité
ou de la connaissance une histoire est
longue et toi aussi les relations
commencent comment on fait pour
pour expliquer puis la saf et
condescendant un peu mais comment on
fait pour pour faire surgir la
connaissance à ce qu'il te parler moyen
d'une technique le magic qui en 10 15
minutes que mon sens ce n'est pas tout
le monde mais ça peut changer les
agences et de pouvoir parler d'une
technique avec la conversation
épistémique sais quoi je me dis que je
vais vous dire je me base énormément sur
anthony magna bosco lui il fait des
vidéos sur internet audio des
conversations et puisse tenir avec des
gens il reste au texas il ya des
conversations sur n'importe quelle
croyance ça peut être religion dieu
carmaux le racisme sexisme tout ce que
vous pouvez penser puis la conversation
épistémique qu'est ce que c'est c'est
justement fait pour éviter le retour de
flamme un second temps d'éviter le
retour de forme de ses cordiale c'est
gentil c'est respectueux ce soit dans la
confrontation c'est pas dans la
confrontation il faut être extrêmement
gentil tout le long je tiens à vous dire
une chose si ça peut aider les gens à
être gentil ça se peut que c'est nous
qui ont requis à montendre un mois
c'était toujours dans cette optique le
que je vous écoute ça se peut que tu
sais la personne en face que la vérité
ça se peut très bien mais ensemble on va
être capable de trouver si les méthodes
qui utilisés sont fiables donc sa part
de turkish tiens à vous dire - vous avez
des connaissances sur le sujet mieux
c'est
pourquoi parce que vous n'allez pas être
influencée par les connaissances que
vous allez maintenant moi je fais j'ai
conversation épistémique 6,5 g moi ça va
peut-être plus difficile parce que j'ai
étudié en physique je sais c'est quoi le
sens que je sais c'est quoi les
fréquences
mais quelqu'un que aucune connaissance
il peut très bien faire une conversation
est pisté me mets en qu'est ce que c'est
première chose
c'est quoi que la personne croit la
première question c'est mettons la
personne est anti vaccins vont reprendre
un exemple très simple la personne est
anti vaccins ok jusqu'à quel pourcentage
tu crois que c'est vrai c'est à dire 100
% t'es sûr que c'est vrai dans l'absolu
même sens même si tu existes épaule puis
0 % c'est sûr que c'est faux donc très
souvent la personne va donner un chiffre
au dessus de 50 mettons à donne 4 qui
s'y adonnent pas 100 % des gens on voit
que assemble déjà est ouvert à l'idée
qu'a pu savoir table sur cd et même si à
dix ans pour cent ces programmes si vous
regardez des vidéos d'antanimena bascoul
la majorité des gens vont dire 100 % au
début de la conversation quinze minutes
plus tard ils vont des 81 75 c'est
vraiment parce qu'en fait le but la
conversation épistémique c'est juste
c'est l'équivalent de mettre un caillou
dans le soulier de la personne donc
ailleurs je pense encore cnca mais juste
un doute dans l'esprit
donc première chose qu est ce que la
personne croit jusqu'à quel nom sans taj
deuxième chose pourquoi elle croise
c'est très important parce que
je vous donne un exemple sur un vidéo
qu'anthony en fait il y avait quelqu'un
que il y avait un tee shirt que c'était
la pornographie ruine le blâme ou
quelque chose comme ça quand il a posé
la question pourquoi il pensait se
savait même pas de lien avec la
pornographie savais même pas de lien
avec la mort ça fait un lien avec le
fait que la personne était religieuse
puis ses valeurs religieuses sont
beaucoup plus importantes et c'est pour
ça que ça donc on aurait pu y aurait pu
avoir une conversation des heures de
teint sur ce alors que ces mêmes
politiques pourquoi la personne il lui
est à penser à ça donc c'est bien
important de savoir pourquoi que la
personne passe mais dont l'exemple du
vaccin - parce que je mets donc essayons
de garder un exemple si on va garder un
exemple la femme étant l'exemple de
vaccins la personne et contre le vaccin
à 80% si les
commandes de vaccins à 100% ok là la
raison pour laquelle
admettons que tu poses la question que
la personne te réponds que c'est pas
parce qu'à l'apport du vaccin
mais parce que
parce que c'est impossible parce que
c'est le grand acquis qui vient poser
quelque chose ok vin la place de
débattre autour c'est sûr des anges et
comme tels du vaccin mais le tu
comprends que c'est pas à cause de ça
fait que tu comprends mieux sur quoi
ouais exactions et mettons sur le
contrôle du gouvernement mme royal est
encore plus drastique que les
lionnes croyances vraiment forte qui dit
que les vaccins donne l'autisme
même si ça a été une fraude et où la
personne à l'époque à y croire puis on
peut comprendre la personne qui sait si
les vaccins donne l'autisme m pas dans
les lotissements enfin c'est tout à fait
légitime de penser c'est tout à fait
correct on peut comprendre que la
personne avait peur donc tu comprend le
pourquoi avait pas donné un vaccin à son
enfant maintenant le plus important de
la conversation épistémique c'est le cas
qu'il faut poser le plus de questions
possibles séquelles sont les méthodes
que la personne ont utilisé pour
déterminer que ce qu'elle pense c'est
vrai donc on peut dire ok les vaccins
donne le tice par exemple où tu vu ce
que j'ai vu sur dans une étude ok on
peut poser la question est ce que toutes
les études qui ont été faites dans le
monde sont totalement vrai déjà juste ça
la personne à avoir pensé avant faire
non probablement qu avant d'y renoncer à
ce que disent oui mais dépend d'un
masque ce qu'a dit faut aller dans cette
direction début que dans les deux années
c'est un bon oui ou non et de kohat
c'est à boston
oui parce que si la réponse est oui
c'est acquis mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec des études existent de la part des
contrats oui c'est ça c'est un peu ce en
fait ce qu'il faut faire avec la
conversation épistémique sait déceler
les contradictions et les incohérences
dans taille de la terre c'est vraiment
ça puis il faut pas dire il faut
toujours poser des questions il ne faut
jamais dire puis il faut poser des
questions genre mais qu'est ce que tu
dirais si tu penser comme moi tout est
faux faut vraiment posé il faut que la
personne elle-même parce que le
raisonnement face le raisonnement paraît
demain puis ça marche bien la personne
très souvent à se rencontrent par
elle-même que ce crime les méthodes que
j'ai utilisées sont pas aussi fiables
que ce jeu soit peut-être y repenser si
j'avais quelque chose à vous dire
la conversation épistémique fonctionne
moins bien avec des gens qu'on connaît
des jours parce que la personne avoue
connais tu es hors jeu c'est une petite
enveloppe si la personne dire je suis
petit envoie exxon c'est fini le temps
ça me fout les personnes parce que ça
pourrait penser que tu pense peut-être
comme lui le groupe mais je suis curieux
de ce curieux puis je les utilisais à
quelques reprises puis c'est les
conversations sont le fun c'est vraiment
agréable c'est vraiment agréable d'avoir
une conversation je les fait avec du
monde qui croient à la numérologie je
les fait avec des témoins de jéhovah je
les fais tu avais c'est vraiment le
faire
avec
c'est vraiment agréable de comprendre
comment la paix depuis on en apprend
plus sur les gens moi je trouve ça
fantastique parce que c'est cordiale et
on est gentil
picholine faut toujours se dire est que
la personne peut être la vérité c'est
peut-être qu'ils se trompent parce que
quelqu'un si on dit vous dites vous bien
quelque chose peu importe les croyances
que vous avez dans vos têtes
si vous en avez une qui est à 100% le
jour que vous allez faire des
conversations épistémique vous aurez
plus jamais être contraint croyance à
100% ni même que la terre est ronde ni
même que la tombe existe peu importe les
critiques que vous avez en tacles mais
vous allez toujours vous dire je
j'accepte l'idée que je peux me tromper
j'accepte l'idée que je puisse avoir
temps puis la conversation épistémique à
être beaucoup et sont donc soyez
cordiale qu'est ce que la personne croit
pourquoi y croit et quelles sont les
méthodes qu'elle a utilisé pour se
rendre compte si c'est vrai puis
questionné les méthodes comme si j'avais
donné l'exemple de lille je les lui dans
une étude ou à telle personne ne dit
rien d'autorité qui médite dispo
argument d'autorité et son fils non ok
est ce que tout ce que cette personne le
dis est vrai
très souvent la personne
mais peut-être pas totalement mais pour
ce qui est de lodsys qui déçoit c'est
sûr que c'est vrai hockey hockey
quel serait le meilleur argument que tu
pourrais me donner pour dire que les
vaccins causes de l'autisme
c'est quoi ton meilleur argument parce
que peut-être que anneaux donc à l'opt
elle a sûrement projet son argument là
peut-être plusieurs arguments puis
qu'ils soient fallait surnom c'est pas
important c'est comprendre comment elle
est arrivée à penser que c'est vrai les
déceler les incohérences et les
contradictions
et pourrait le mieux c'est d'en voir
anthony magna bosco il y en a fait
depuis des fois en cinq minutes la
personne croit ce soir je regardais ça
depuis tout petit et croissants pour ça
puis j'ai vu sept minutes plus tard
je sais pas le temps que les personnes
changent d c'est juste que le temps ait
pu certaines rues certains aimeraient
pas besoin de l'importance ces caisses
qui s'écoute votre but si votre but est
faire changer d'avis la personne n'avait
pas un bon but le vôtre si votre but est
de trouver la vérité là vous avez un bon
but puis d'avoir une discussion cordiale
avec la personne là vous êtes en
business et si vous vous dites ok je
serai capable de jaser avec lui ou elle
puis que ce soit le fun c'est bon puis
en fait je vous dirais je vais juste de
penser à soc
pour savoir si vous êtes vraiment
intéressé par la vérité un petit est ce
que j'aime bien c'est
le ton vous avez une croyance entre
n'importe où même une connaissance parce
que des fois on croit savoir
de 0 à 10 jusqu'à combien êtes vous
intéressé par la vérité a dit si je suis
intéressé à 100% que par la vérité de la
question de la croyance be 06 je suis
pas intéressé du tout ça m'importe peu
je m'en fous
maintenant si je vous pose une deuxième
question c'est
jusqu'à quel point m vous prêt à aller
voir ce que les gens qui ne pensent pas
comme vous dis c'est quoi leur argument
jusqu'à 10
et ensuite vous fait le ratio entre les
deux le ratio entre les deux c'est
comment vous êtes vraiment intéressé par
la vérité parce que si vous êtes
vraiment intéressé par la vérité les
nombres de brett égard parce que si vous
êtes intéressé à 100% la vérité
normalement vous devriez à 100% aller
voir ceux qui ne pensent pas comme vous
ça me faisait penser sur le
g7
cette discussion là où amour de faire
surgir la vérité au détriment mais au
détriment en laissant de côté propre
billet ouais on dirait que c'est le
contraire du discours public oui oui
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on entend de
ce convoi de l'opinion c'est le contrat
d'aidé beau temps on parlait on parlait
avant hier un souhait de
d'une exercice de pensée on parlait du
véganisme qui sait on imaginait une
exercer un exercice de pensée ou est ce
qu'il y avait
2,2 personnes qui rentrent dans une
discussion inquiet vegan 1 qu'il ait pas
qu'ils rentrent dans une discussion
autour de l'éthique du véganisme temps
qui écrit que les deux arrivés avec
l'idée de faire jaillir la vérité
de la conversation fait qu'en étant
intellectuellement honnête mettons en
tirer point puisque on imaginait c'est
qu'au final c'était même la personne qui
éprouve egan dirait le véganisme est la
bonne chose à faire pour la planète les
animaux et l'environnement exact puis ce
genre de conversation là où est-ce que
tu arrives sens l'idée de confronter ou
de faire valoir son opinion mais juste
d'essayer de comprendre de faire jaillir
la vérité dans le fond il y en a pas -
ça se fait pas puis en fait la personne
un peu points
je posais mes chabat peut pas en vouloir
parce que on était vraiment intéressé
parce que kddi 2 tu fais pas
d'affirmations tu ne fais que poser des
questions petit intéresse vraiment à ça
puis pour ce qui est du débat public
j'aime pas de temps les débats publics
pour une certaine raison là il j'appelle
quasiment plus des débats rationnelle
merci ce débat public débat rationnel
ses moutons des gens qui vont vraiment
argumenté avoir des arguments qui vont
ils vont se ranger du côté des meilleurs
arguments mais les débats publics
on dirait que je vois ça comme mettons
quelqu'un qui voit un débat dans une
université une conférence il vaut pas un
débat en espérant changer d'avis
s'il est des deux côtés des deux comtés
pied je parle même créationnistes versus
évolution le laisser quoi que
l'évolution du
change my mind est une preuve comme pas
changé d'idée mais la plupart des bottes
et un débat politique tel et les
policiers ils ne souhaitent pas
des chefs à vous avez raison c'est un
bon point que j'avais pas pensé
et la conversation épistémique
je tiens dit quelque chose par contre
dans le débat public ça fonctionne moins
bien parce que plus il ya de monde qui
assiste
plus là la possibilité d'interagir et
grands des dons - ya des chances que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne mieux mettons
en oeuvre parce que le on est vraiment
ensemble on est vraiment on se pose
vraiment des questions mais si on met on
avait une foule pions je dirais on était
ensemble puis la foule interagit web et
ne pas penser à cbc il suffit qu'une
personne vienne casser pitt ces crises
des insultes ou n'importe quoi des deux
côtés il a fait des beaux public j'en
veux un peu moins sommet c'est pour ça
que je privilégie la conversation
épistémique lorsque vous êtes même si ça
fonctionne peut-être moins bien avec les
gens connaissez vous pouvez l'essayer
pareil c'est fait pas un débat fait
juste qu'ils posaient des questions puis
ça fonctionne moins bien sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que tu vois pour la
personne quand tu vois la personne c'est
beaucoup plus
je peux dire un embellissement métissée
c'est beau c'est
exact c'est humain hippiques et des fois
tu te réponds non surpris des médias
sociaux la personne peut penser que j'ai
répondu non non non
avec sursis quand personne c'est mieux
mais ça se fait quand même sur les
réseaux sociaux anthony mann dabo school
de fait sur tracteur alors qu'ils
arrêtent d'autres mondes qui
interagissent et c'est là que vu que
quand
ça marche mais ça m'a vraiment moins
bien donc pour ce que je privilégie
voilà donc faites le si vous voulez avec
votre famille vos amis de vue une fois
vidéo sur pc quel médical est justement
dans un vrai lit de trump le typique et
poser des questions aux gens qui étaient
l'observant confrontation c'est vraiment
juste de comprendre de le leur pensée le
tpiy mais souvent this était vraiment de
l'ordre la croyance puis je te demande
pas ouvert à l'échangé d'idées pas
trouver la vérité le tipi la question
c'était quelque chose que dans le tome
frais que vous qui
ferez changer d'idée mettons vous
apprenez qui est qui qui tue et des dvd
des bébés la rentabilité oui oui j'avais
vu sur pc comme non je voudrais quand
même pour lui c'est flou c'est comme
acquis le 10 mai mme lee vous êtes
convaincu convaincu et ne rien voir la
carène père quand je vais faire une
petite nuance ici que j'ai vu dans une
conférence de techniques de bosco lui il
faut continuer à avoir la conversation
épistémique parce que c'est pas parce
que la personne de dick oeil aurélien
qui va le faire changer d'avis que
vraiment rien qui m'ont changé d'avis
mieux donner un exemple sur neil
degrasse tyson qui est un astrophysicien
quand même assez bien connu le dis c'est
quoi les preuves que je il y avait un
ami ou chapeau qu'une connaissance je
pense qu'ils aient qui croyaient que la
terre était plate lequel sont les
preuves que je pourrais tu as menée pour
que la tâche soit bon enfant comme seul
puis il ya dix ans et j'aimerais que tu
m'amènes so so so so so parfait
prestations sociales la personne en fait
non non je crois encore que je sais pas
si la terre plate le mais peu importe
une certaine croyance pile au niveau de
la station et 10 and what you see c'est
fini ce qui changera pas d'avis mais
anthony magna beau trop ce qu'ils disent
et c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire en fait
ce que la personne a vraiment dit c'est
que c'est pas c'est finalement pas sûr
qu'ils vont la faire changer d'avis il
faut pour
faut pas perdre espoir en ces personnes
là même si vous disent que rien va les
faire changer d'avis sas peur qu'un jour
ils changent quand même d'avis même si
dans le fond ce que ce que cette
personne là il ya voulu dire à neil
degrasse tyson c'est que finalement
c'était pas ce qui me permettait de
fâches de changer d'avis c'est peut-être
autre chose et saviez surtout avec le
pourquoi tu y ait de quoi pourquoi quand
le pourquoi la personne croit à ce
peut-être que la personne croit que la
terre est plate pour certaines autres
raisons qui donnent pas dit à lyon de
die zeit paul pour couiza exact sera
peut-être parler de quelque chose vous
allez peut-être pas parler de la même
chose sinon c'est ça exactement puis
admettons avec des conversations
épistémique avec déjà le religieux bain
très souvent la religion ça donne c'est
je dis ça mais un espoir dans leur vie
pour la vie après la mort ça leur donne
des valeurs ils suivent certaines choses
crime ça aïe ça les a aidé les actifs
imagine tu veux pas anthony magna bosco
et 10 pour ce qui est des fois dans le
pourquoi tu veux pas nécessairement
faire changer d'avis la personne parce
que cela aide la personne autiste tu te
rends compte que je sais pas une femme a
perdu son mari puis l'aed est rentré
dans une certaine ces dommages là de
dire qu'elle est rentrée dans une secte
ou quelque chose dans le sol parce que
tu dis que peut-être manipuler tout mais
c'est des fois je te dis ok c'est quoi
le port et les barons de dire est ce que
est ce que mon but c'est vraiment
différent a changé d'avis on a beau être
pire si à change t faut vraiment faire
attention avec ce type était depuis
début chaotique car on pas
d'argumentation qui compare le biais
cognitif quand on parle des
connaissances qu'on parle de science
c'est très dense dans l'objectivité puis
dans la rationalité tandis que j'ai bien
des fois qu'ils aient raison justement
qu'il allait prendre vos propos vous
croire quelque chose ces professionnels
ccc émotionnel pc ici c'est pour des
raisons complètement autre motif moi
j'ai une amie qui l'a ceinturé jc puis
fait longtemps que le connaître ses
pieds tellement eu souvent des
discussions ou je te battais plus
d'aller dans les questions que dans le
jugement ou qui dans con tration
vraiment c'est de comprendre ces puits
pitt issus souvent justement t on à on
arrive power
point critique mais un genre de
désaccord il n'y a pas grand chose qui
va me faire changer d'idées qui habitait
au final
c'est probablement plus des raisons
justement d'appartenance un bruit exacte
de sa petite clique qui ciblent dépasse
le rationnel télé oui et c'est difficile
à imaginer quelqu'un qui est dans la
sociologie ou n'importe quoi un groupe
quelconque il a tout ce qu'ils croient
depuis le début de sa vie que sa famille
croit que son voisinage quoi que son
ensemble quoi que ses amis croient
pilot vous êtes en train de le faire
chambouler s'est offert le champion
changer d'avis seul ace incroyablement
difficile
ça prend un courage extrême de traiter
de vouloir accepter le fait qu est ce
que tu crois depuis le début ou depuis
longtemps ce serait pas ça serait pas
nécessairement en vrille et maintenant
je pense que c'est faux mais ce ne
serait pas nécessairement rien puis a
écrit mme le pen peut-être pas de perdre
ton appartenance c'est pour ça que des
fois dans le pourquoi on va se rendre au
keops le los teques je veux pas il faut
en changer d'avis peut-être que t on on
va s'en tenir à voir d'autres
discussions puis c'est pour ça que même
anthony magda bosco il donne des
exemples que il a arrêté la conversation
s'il ya vraiment fait pas je te souhaite
une bonne journée
arrêtez la conversation donc c'est pour
ça que des fois en comprenant le
pourquoi on peut comprendre que on veut
pas continuer dans cette voie là donc
c'est faux c'est vraiment faut vraiment
être respectueux envers les gens pour
sur le disent allez-y m c'est sûr c'est
notre jugement chacun a donc des fois on
peut penser bien faire alors que mais
enfin peu importe le morceau dans le
pourquoi c'est important aussi
c'est vraiment facile
si les gens ils veulent
ils veulent tentant de plus les gens qui
nous écoutent le qu'est-ce qu'ils font
qui est une moyenne de moyens de lire ce
que tu fais de jeu tu entraînes d'écrire
un livre mais ça sera pas publié avant
un certain temps parce que c'est
vraiment long j'obtiens docteur
le projet de recherche
et ce soit mon courriel c'est mon nom
anthony pons et bertrand point grenier
commercial gmail.com
anthony pau 2 h le feu pour piller dans
la dispense d'écrire dans la description
c'est une manière de me rejoindre donc
je suis pas je viens à peine de
découvrir les podcasts dans le nord de
la colline le nom des gens à chaque fois
je redécouvre le j écoute
jeunes à découvrir
donc c'est ça j'ai fait ce livre que
myriam chez vous je veux voir si jamais
je vois
mais voilà donc s'en écoule way bonjour
merci merci mais en fait de conduite de
voir publiquement ce qui est vraiment
fascinant et tous
merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin j'espère que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et sans
fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup si vous voulez voir
plus de contenus plus de conversations
sur pétillante que ça se passe bien sûr
p tu es un non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce
qu'on les tombes donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pictural où
est ce que on parle d'homme n'est que
l'émoi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur une
page de turenne les le lien vers savoir
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois de nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fonte